Haiii...
Welcome back, lady!
Hello!
Welcome...
to...
Metal Gear Solid...
3!
Yippee!
My voice is like...
I did karaoke yesterday and my voice is kind of dead so...
Whoopsie!
Thank you for the pink!
Thank you!
Oh, save the line, boss.
Kept you waiting, huh?
Yay!
So, um...
Yeah!
Oh my gosh!
Wait, can you guys hear it?
Just so... I can never remember what you guys can... if you guys can hear it or not.
No?
Okay, now you'll be able to hear it.
Now you'll be able to hear it.
Thank you for using my remix!
Thank you, Rob!
Thanks for the remix!
Sorry, I just kind of stole your video.
Sorry, I just kind of...
took it for my own.
But I hope you don't mind.
I was like, gonna use just the audio, but then I was like, the whole video is kind of cool.
I was like, I kind of...
I want like the... I want your credit on the screen, you know?
So...
Haven't been able to play any of the Metal Gear games myself, so being able to experience the games for the first time with my Kamiyoshi...
Let's go!
Oh my gosh.
So...
I'll be honest.
You know, with Metal Gear Solid 1 and Metal Gear Solid 2, I've kind of like...
touched them again, I guess?
Since the first time I played it.
But actually, with Metal Gear Solid 3...
I have not really played this since the first time I played it.
So, I've been very nervous about this game in particular.
Replaying it again.
So, I'm just like...
That's not to say...
That's not to say I haven't watched other people play it.
Because there's like a 24-hour Metal Gear livestream thing that I just kind of have on in the background a lot of my days.
What about the 3DS version?
Oh!
I played the 3DS version.
Um...
Of Metal Gear Solid 3.
Up to like...
Sokolov.
So, I didn't get very far.
Like, I didn't even get to...
Operation Snake Eater.
I just kind of...
Oh!
Snake Eater!
I...
It's...
I did not...
I just did not like playing it on such a small screen.
It's basically it, you know?
Is that Subsistence?
Yes!
So, today we will be playing the Subsistence version.
I've got my Playstation...
My PS2...
All set up...
For this.
So...
Um...
Yeah, I am playing Subsistence.
So, there will be a few little differences...
Between...
Um...
Like the HD collection and this as well.
And...
If you are curious...
Yes, it does have that...
Dream sequence in it.
So...
And...
The...
What's interesting to me too is...
In this, you can switch between like...
The original Metal Gear Solid 3 camera...
And then the...
Updated...
Subsistence one.
So, yeah.
I mean those sad podcast over happy you're back.
Thank you.
Actually, well, there's still...
Two episodes left of the podcast.
Well, technically one episode and then one...
Bonus thing.
So...
Thanks to the five gifters.
This ghost is looking kind of funky.
I don't know what you're talking about.
But, yeah.
So...
Um...
Just wanted to say thank you.
I'm just gonna kind of go for it.
And...
Um...
Today...
Uh...
I'll be honest.
Still fighting that jet lag.
So bad.
I'm not sure how far we'll get.
Um...
Definitely through...
Like...
At least...
You know...
Virtuous mission.
Which is not very long at all.
But...
Um...
I mean...
Sorry.
Virtual mission.
And...
Um...
Like...
How long did you sleep for?
Oh my gosh.
I went to bed last night at like 3 a.m.
And then I woke up at my...
Like naturally I woke up at like 6 a.m.
And then...
I couldn't get back to sleep.
I took a nap about like two hours ago.
For like an hour.
So...
My...
My brain is just waking me up so early for some reason.
This is so annoying.
Jet lagged the secret member of the cover unit.
But I have some coffee here.
I have some...
Canned coffee.
And yeah.
I'm ready baby.
I think it's because...
When I was in Japan...
I mean...
To be fair...
I was there for a whole month.
So...
You know...
My soul really adjusted while I was there.
But...
I also didn't drink so much caffeine while I was over there.
And now I'm drinking caffeine to make myself like awake and excitable for stream.
So...
You know how it is.
I mean to I'm alive.
Saku!
I put in a request to have my relocation delayed till after Christmas.
I hope that works.
Detox blues.
Thank you!
You're awesome!
What's this!
What is this!
What in the world is this!
Less caffeine but there's tea everywhere.
But I drink a lot of tea.
When I'm at my maid cafe.
Like I am constantly drinking tea.
And because in Japan...
I drink like...
A lot of, um...
Especially because it was so hot.
I would drink a lot of vitamin drinks.
I would drink a lot of tomato juice.
I would drink a lot of fr diary sweat and stuff like that.
So.
It wasn't...
I just...
Mostly tea, that I was drinking.
MGS3, you'll probably like this one.
We'll see.
I'm going in with an open mind.
So yeah.
Let's begin, I suppose.
Here we
go.
Shino, thanks for the 20 gifted.
Oh, just kidding.
Now I press start.
New game.
I should say I like MGS2.
But it's true.
I do like MGS2.
I'm playing the MGS series for the first time.
Be honest.
I do.
I like MGS2.
Normal.
After the end of World War 2, the world was split into two.
East and West.
This marked the beginning of the era called the Cold War.
Oh gosh.
I'm not normal.
I'm not normal at all.
Oh god.
Oh no.
I just hear his voice.
Oh my gosh.
I've met so many of these people now.
Which is so insane to think about.
Oh my gosh.
I've met so many of these people now.
I've met...
Actually...
I'm going to be adjusting the audio.
I've got to intervene.
Oh, I'm getting ready to...
It was that guy called...
Okay.
At the beginning, I...
yeah.
I was...
Oh...
I think he went to the second floor.
Yes.
I completely forgot.
I know I just picked it, but I completely forgot that he has it on right now too.
Does this panty waste know what he's doing?
Panty waste.
Approaching release point.
10 minutes to drop off.
Hey, are you deaf?
He said put out the cigar and put on your mask.
Hey, that's no that's no way to talk to a hero.
A legend.
Of panty waste.
Yeah, I'd call Ryde in that too.
Decrystallization complete.
Checking oxygen supply.
Six minutes to drop off.
Opening rear hatch.
I'm really... I really wanted to get back on this too as soon as I got back from Japan too because...
Sunrise.
Delta soon?
External temperature minus 46 degrees Celsius.
Two minutes to drop off.
Delta eventually.
No, Delta demo soon.
For me?
Hopefully.
Try not to get frostbite from the wind chill.
One minute to drop off.
Move to the rear.
What'd you say about my rear?
This is one for the history books.
The world's first halo jump.
Oh my gosh, the world's first halo jump!
10 seconds to drop off.
Standby.
Status okay?
All green.
Prepare for drop off.
Do a flip.
spread your wings and fly.
I hope they redub that part where he says, do a flip instead.
NOOOOOOOOoo.
See?
he's listening.
He listens to me.
He's not spreading any wings.
He's flipping around..
This is the game based on the pachinko machine?
Yeah.
Jack, I've got some important news.
The head of the CIA has finally given us the green light for the Virtuous Mission.
Virtual Mission?
No, the Virtuous Mission.
The future of our FOX unit depends on it.
If it succeeds, we'll be officially organized into a unit.
Virtuous Mission?
Sounds like some kind of initiation ritual.
Don't get cocky, this isn't a training op.
Right.
So what exactly is this wonderful mission?
This wonderful mission...
About two years ago, a certain Soviet scientist requested asylum in the West through one of our...
So crunchy!
His name is Nikolai Stepanovich Sokolov.
He's head of the OKB-754 Design Bureau.
He has a middle name!
I just always call him Sokolov.
Sokolov?
I never even think about his whole name.
And the East's foremost expert on weapons development.
Sokolov?
Isn't he that famous rocket scientist?
The very same.
What is this?
On April 12, 1961, the Soviets achieved the first manned spaceflight in history.
The Earth was blue, but there was no God.
Well spoken.
The rocket that carried Yuri Gagarin to orbit was the A-1, known as the Vostok rocket.
Snake just pulling anything out of his...
Sokolov is said to be the man...
most responsible for the multi-engine cluster used in that rocket.
Not major being like...
After Gagarin's flight, Sokolov left rocket development to become the head of the newly established design bureau.
From a lowly technician to head of a design bureau, that's quite a success story.
So why'd he want to defect?
It seems he'd become afraid of his own creations.
Afraid?
As they all do.
Call it a crisis of conscience.
And for that, he left his country and his family behind...
and went over the fence.
Not exactly.
One of his conditions was that his family was also to be taken safely to the west.
We used a mole to get the family out first...
and succeeded in sneaking Sokolov over the Berlin Wall shortly afterwards.
I was the one who conducted the operation.
Okay, what do you want?
A medal?
You want a pat on your back?
Shut up, Major.
A cookie?
It took him two weeks and more than 600 miles to get from the research facility in the Soviet Union to Berlin.
He was in no condition to say anything coherent.
Oh my gosh.
And it was only a week later that we had something much bigger on our mind.
Real people!
The Cuban Missile Crisis.
Crisis!
On October 16, 1962, President Kennedy received word that the Soviets were in the process of deploying...
Oh my god!
...intermediate-range ballistic missiles from Cuba.
JFK!
He demanded that the Soviets dismantle and remove the missiles.
At the same time, he announced a naval blockade to prevent further missile shipments from reaching Cuba.
But the Soviets didn't back down, instead placing their armed forces on secondary alert.
Soviet transport ships carrying missiles continued on course towards Cuba.
They're so angry.
U.S.
and Soviet forces went on alert for an all-out nuclear war.
Frantic negotiations were conducted...
Real people!
...through the U.N.'s Emergency Security Council and unofficial channels to end the hair-trigger standoff.
Finally, on October 28, the Soviet Union agreed to remove its missiles from Cuba.
What would these leaders think of all this footage being used in a video game?
And so the world avoided a nuclear holocaust.
What would these world leaders think?
But in order to get the Soviets to pull their missiles out, we had to make a deal.
You mean the one where the U.S.
agreed to remove its IRBMs from Turkey?
No.
The Jupiter IRBMs deployed in Turkey were obsolete, and we were going to get rid of them anyway.
Yeah, they'd be like, what's a video game?
They'd be like, what's a video game?
The Turkey deal was a ruse.
A ruse?
A cover story was fed to the other intelligence agencies around the world.
So what did the Russians really want?
Sokolov.
They wanted us to return to Sokolov.
They want him.
You mean the Soviets pulled out of Cuba just to get their hands on Sokolov?
Sokolov.
That's right.
What the hell was he working on?
At the time, we had no idea.
Because he was getting my past high school history.
We were running out of time.
It was either give up Sokolov or risk full-scale nuclear war.
Understandable.
In the end, we had no choice.
President Kennedy gave in to Khrushchev's demand.
The next day, I got Sokolov out of the hospital.
Handing him over to agents on the eastern side.
He looks like he's like stumbling over.
Sokolov kept on screaming, save me, until he disappeared from my sight.
I can't even tell what's going on in this picture.
Then a month ago, we received some new information from one of our moles.
Who took that?
You need to fire them.
About Sokolov?
Yes.
He was taken back to the research facility and forced to continue working on the weapon in question under KGB supervision.
Bigfoot camera work.
I didn't take that picture.
So what kind of weapon is it?
Something to do with space rockets?
Space rockets?
No, missiles.
Missiles.
Same technology.
I guess you're right.
We don't know the details, but it appears to be a new kind of nuclear device.
Oh.
For half a year now, the Soviets have been conducting frequent nuclear tests at Semipalatinsk.
Some kind of nuclear device?
We're talking about a secret weapon so big that Khrushchev was ready to pull out of Cuba to get it back.
Is Sokolov still in the facility?
No.
According to our intelligence, he's in Selenoyarsk, a place in the mountains about three miles to the west that's known as the Virgin Cliffs.
The Virgin Cliffs?
Don't say it like that.
That's mean for a virtuous mission.
They moved him there just recently.
Why?
This man.
Apparently, they're conducting a field test of the weapon, but it's our best chance to get him back.
The Virgin Cliffs.
This mission would never have been possible if he was still in the research facility.
This is our last chance.
Sokolov must have known that too when he contacted us.
Snake you dog.
He's like, I can make them the not Virgin Cliffs.
I can make them the un... I can...
Keep
the Cliffs away from Steg.
The Cliffs are in danger!
We'd have to update all the maps!
Don't let him do it!
It's a pain in the neck!
I'll have you...
This part's cooler, though, I think.
Seeing it from our vision.
If we don't get Sokolov back before that weapon is complete, we'll be facing a major crisis.
Ugh, crisis!
The clock is ticking.
Once we've confirmed the rescue of Sokolov, stand by at the recovery point.
A recovery balloon will be dropped at that point.
Helium will be pumped into the balloon to inflate it.
The process takes about 20 minutes.
Okay.
Once it's complete, the gunship's arm will latch onto the balloon and pull it up.
The Fulton surface-to-air recovery system.
I'm familiar with the theory.
Take it easy.
It's been combat proven.
Do you think Sokolov is up to it?
The shock will be less than during a parachute jump, and the arm can handle up to 500 pounds.
Yay, Fulton!
So you're planning on going over the border in a single combat talent?
...
She's equipped with two six-barrel 20mm Vulcan cannons, as well as two 40mm machine guns.
Oh, okay.
Sounds like she could hold her own against a battalion of tanks.
Even with the fuel in the reserve tank, we're facing a four-hour time limit.
If all goes well, it shouldn't take more than a few hours.
Home in time for dinner.
But if anything goes wrong...
You'll be eating dinner, breakfast, and all the rest of your meals in the jungle.
No!
He's probably okay with that.
We know what Snake likes.
He wants some more.
Boss, when are you going to do a Halo jump?
Uhhh...
, so...never.
Woah!
Hehehe.
Woah...
And now...
I knew it was coming, but it's still so jarring.
Why do I have to do that?
And now...
Woah...
The jungles of Russia.
And now...
Russia!
Who is that?
Oh my gosh!
That silver hair...
That stance!
Those big, big thighs!
It's Raiden!
Jack!
Jack is back, baby!
Oh my gosh!
I'm playing Metal Gear Solid 3 again.
I hear some rustling.
I think I hear some...
SOME WILDLIFE!
Look, we got our calorie maze!
It's baby girl Raiden.
A balanced nutrition food.
Nice!
Oh!
What's down here?
What do you think it is?
It's...
A frog!
Yippee!
Cut
the grass!
Cut the grass!
Let's go get our bag, I suppose.
So, if I press...
I think it's the right analog stick.
Look!
This...
Oh my gosh!
This is original Metal Gear Solid 3 camera.
Hello!
Do you copy?
You're already in enemy territory.
Somebody might be listening in.
From here on out, we'll be using code names to refer to each other.
Your code name for this mission will be Naked Snake.
I'll be referring to you as Snake from now on.
You're not to mention your real name.
Snake!
But you don't like snakes?
What do you mean?
You've eaten one before, haven't you?
In survival training.
I'm glad to hear that.
I don't know if I'd ever order one in a restaurant, but...
Be careful.
You might not have a choice.
He's gonna have an affinity.
What should I call you?
Let's see.
I'll be...
I'll be Tom.
Call me Major Tom.
Oh, and Snake?
The crew isn't watching anymore.
You can take off the disguise now.
Good idea.
This isn't right.
Time for the snake to shed his skin.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so excited.
Oh my gosh!
Oh my god!
Jungles of Russia, jungles of...
The way he's looking around.
He's taking it all in.
Yeah, we gotta get our bag first.
We gotta get our bag first.
Oh my god, this clunky codec.
It's the boy!
There's our man!
Can you hear me, Major Tom?
This is Snake.
It's Plisky.
This will be a sneaky mission.
You must not be seen by the enemy.
You must leave no trace of your presence.
Is that clear?
This kind of infiltration is the Fox Unit's speciality.
Speciality?
In other words, weapons and equipment are procured on site.
That goes for food as well.
You're completely naked, just as your name implies.
Great.
Now I see why you asked me if I like snakes.
I suppose calling me Snake was your idea of a joke too.
I'll tell you later when the time is right.
Gotcha.
Does he never tell us?
How exactly am I supposed to feed myself?
You've been issued a knife and a tranquilizer gun.
Use them to hunt for food.
You'll also find some medical supplies in your backpack.
Yeah, but...
Not the backpack.
I lost it in a tree on the way down.
I see.
Well, you'd better go back and get it then.
I remember...
No problem.
I can see it from here.
It's stuck on a branch.
Kojima said that snake just sounded cool.
Solid snake.
To climb a tree, stand in front of a tree that's covered in ivy and press the action button.
I'll be monitoring your progress over the radio.
We can't risk violating Soviet airspace, but I'll be in the gunship.
I think he says Y in the codec.
We'll just have to hear it again.
My frequency is one four zero point eight five.
I'll give you a call if I need to talk to you.
One four zero point eight five.
If you need to talk to me, use the send function.
Send.
Okay, snake.
Go get your backpack.
Okay.
I'm going to school.
Can't wait for flaccid snake.
No, don't say that.
Is he already in?
Okay, good.
Oh.
Snake, first you need to find that backpack you lost on the way down.
Okay.
Your backpack got caught on a tree to the north.
Try heading in that direction.
Okay, bye.
Okay.
Cool.
Okay, I already...
The camera angle for the original...
Like, it's like this.
Which I can see being useful.
Maybe sometimes.
But like...
It's...
This is just...
This is this.
And let's see.
We got our food.
Oh, we only have our food.
Calorie mate.
Tree frog.
We'll save this for later.
Nothing in the cage.
Because, you know...
Some days you might feed on a tree frog.
And...
This might be one of those days.
There's so much rustling.
Oh, gosh!
It's a...
Maybe a reticulated python!
Our snake!
There's my bag.
Okay.
Look at...
Look at this...
Look at this T...
I can't even say the name!
Oh, my gosh!
Look at this...
Look at this T-Rex pose!
Get up there.
Okay, easy.
Easy.
Breezy.
Beautiful.
Cover girl.
I see you've retrieved your backpack, snake.
Yeah.
To equip a weapon, it's necessary to take it out of your backpack.
In the survival viewer, choose weapon from the backpack.
Your available weapons will be displayed in a window in the upper left.
From that list, choose the weapon you want to equip and press the enter button.
For other equipped items, just do the same thing from item.
Got it.
Use the survival viewer backpack.
Backpack.
Yep, that's right.
Survival is fundamental to this mission.
After you've been out in the field for a while, your stamina will start to drop.
If your stamina gets too low, it'll affect your performance.
I think there's gonna be more than that.
And your wounds won't heal as smoothly.
There's gonna be way more of this affecting my performance.
Keep an eye on your stamina so you don't run out.
To recover lost stamina, you can hunt for local flora and fauna.
Flora?
You can use either your tranquilizer gun or your knife to hunt.
My only weapon is a Mark 22 hush puppy tranquilizer gun?
That's right.
It's been fitted with its own suppressor.
Oh my gosh.
However, the suppressor will deteriorate every time you fire.
Once its durability reaches zero, the noise suppression effect will be gone.
So don't get too trigger-happy with it.
The suppressor's durability is shown in the icon.
It's okay, I'll just CQC them.
Any weapons and equipment beyond what you're carrying now, you'll have to find as you go.
Okay.
I have to find my own weapons and equipment?
Whose crazy idea was this, anyway?
Solo covert actions are standard FOX operating procedure.
You can't leave any traces of your presence.
No weapons, equipment, footprints, sweat, or bodily waste.
The same goes for bullets and cartridges, too.
It would be really bad if we had to clean that up, you know?
There aren't supposed to be any American soldiers in Russia.
It could spark an international incident.
You can't let anyone see you.
You can't let the enemy know you're there.
This is a stealth mission.
You're a ghost, Snake.
In every sense of the word.
There'll be no rescue if you're captured.
The military and US government will deny any involvement in the affair.
Then I'll just have to take care of myself, huh?
So, you've been given a fake death pill for that purpose.
In every sense of the word.
Fake death pill.
SIS guidelines stipulate that soldiers on covert ops like this one be issued a potassium cyanide capsule.
You're a ghost, Mint.
Tape it to your body so you can take it with you.
And Harry, you're a wizard.
How generous of you.
Use it if you're taken prisoner by the enemy.
It'll send you into a state of false death for a short time.
Yay, false death!
Who am I to be thinking that I'm really dead?
So, how do I come back to life?
Just take the revival pill.
How would I...
How would I take it, though?
That's the one.
But be careful.
If you remain in a state of false death for too long, nothing will be able to bring you back.
Remember that.
If I'm fake dead, how do I fake alive?
You said this was a solo mission, right?
Right.
I guess that means I can't count on any reinforcements.
Nope.
The mission rests entirely in your hands.
No reinforcements.
Relax.
There's a support team ready to back you up over the radio.
Who?
No.
Survival is of utmost importance.
The first member of the support team will be in charge of monitoring your physical condition.
Acting as a medic, so to speak.
As well as recording your mission data.
She's a member of FOX, as well.
How's the audio, by the way?
Just let me know if I need to turn it up or down.
She.
Hello, Snake.
I'm Paramedic.
Nice to meet you.
Paramedic.
As in a medic who comes in by parachute.
Aren't you going to tell me your real name?
Are you going to tell me yours, Mr. Snake?
No, we're using code names.
My name, huh?
It's John Doe.
And they call you Jack, for short.
You're a regular Captain Nemo.
A name means nothing on the battlefield.
I guess he's also Captain Nemo.
After a week, no one has a name.
What's your name?
Jane Doe.
Very funny.
I wasn't joking, but I'll tell you my name only if you manage to make it back alive.
Oh my gosh.
She took his last name.
My frequency is 145.73.
She's also in charge of recording your mission data.
Whenever you want to save, send a message over the reserved save frequency.
140.96.
So saving lets me record my mission data.
That's right.
It also records the state of your health.
Good to know.
There's one more person I want to introduce you to, Snake.
Speaking of snakes, you remember the boss, don't you?
A legendary soldier and your mentor.
The boss?
Actually, it was the boss that got the DCI's authorization in the first place.
The name means nothing on the battlefields as the guy who just asked for her name true.
Bosses?
She also helped me plan this mission.
She and I were at SAS together.
Oh, I thought she and I were sassy.
How many years has it been?
Boss?
That's right.
It's me.
Talk to me.
Let me hear your voice.
It's been five years.
She's kind of squeaking.
Oh my god, Snake.
You've lost weight.
You can tell just by the sound of my voice.
Of course I can.
I know all about you.
Really?
Well, I don't know anything about you.
What's that supposed to mean?
Why'd you disappear on me all of a sudden?
I was on a top secret mission.
You didn't need me anymore.
Oh my god, hearing the boss's voice...
But there were still so many things I wanted you to teach me.
No.
I taught you everything you needed to know about fighting techniques.
I taught you all I could.
The rest you needed to learn on your own.
Techniques, sure.
But what about how to think like a soldier?
How to think like a soldier?
I can't teach you that.
A soldier needs to be strong in spirit, body, and technique.
And the only thing you can learn from someone else is technique.
In fact, technique doesn't even matter.
What's most important is spirit.
Spirit and body are like two sides of a single coin.
They're the same thing.
I can't teach you how to think.
You'll just have to figure it out for yourself.
Listen to me, Jack.
Just because soldiers are on the same side right now doesn't mean they always will be.
Having personal feelings about your comrades is one of the worst sins you can commit.
Politics determine who you face on the battlefield.
And politics are a living thing.
They change along with the times.
Yesterday's good might be tomorrow's evil.
Is that why you abandoned me?
No.
It had nothing to do with you.
I already told you, Jack.
I was on a top secret mission.
A soldier has to follow whatever orders he's given.
It's not his place to question why.
But you're looking for a reason to fight.
You're a natural born fighter.
But you're not quite a soldier.
I got rookie's eyes.
A soldier is a political tool.
That's doubly true if he's a career soldier.
Right and wrong have no place in his mission.
He has no enemies and no friends.
Only the mission.
I'll let you out once the cuts seem to have run far.
You follow the orders you're given.
That's what being a soldier is.
I'll let you out.
I do whatever I have to to get the job done.
I don't think about politics.
That's not the same thing.
Sooner or later, your conscience is going to bother you.
In the end, you have to choose whether you're going to live as a soldier...
or just another man with a gun.
There's a saying in the orient.
Loyalty to the end.
Do you know what it means?
Being patriotic.
It means devoting yourself to your country.
I follow the president and the top brass.
I'm ready to die for them if necessary.
I'll turn off my noise gate so you can hear her meowing.
The president and the top brass won't be there forever.
Once their terms are up, others will take their place.
I follow the will of the leader.
No matter who's in charge.
People aren't the ones who dictate the mission.
Then who does?
The times.
People's values change over time.
And so do the leaders of a country.
So there's no such thing as an enemy in absolute terms.
The enemies we fight are only enemies in relative terms.
Constantly changing with the times.
This is too much for Snake's tiny brain.
There's no point in believing in anything.
Even in those we love.
And that's the way a soldier's supposed to think?
The only thing we can believe in, with absolute certainty, is the mission, Jack.
Alright, but do me a favor.
What is it?
Call me Snake.
The way he looks up.
Your code name is Snake.
It suits you well.
That's right.
The legendary unit that the boss put together during World War II was a snake.
The Cobra Unit.
A group of heroes that brought the war to an end and saved the world.
As long as you've got a legendary hero backing you up, you'll be fine.
Isn't that right, Snake?
What are you doing, Hurley?
I can't think of anyone else I'd rather have with me.
Oh, and one more thing, boss.
Yes, boss?
It's good to hear your voice again.
Same here.
After all, who knows if either of us will make it out alive.
Snake, you are always best at urban warfare and infiltrating buildings.
But this is the jungle.
Survival is going to be key.
Those CQC techniques I taught you are sure to come in handy.
CQC!
CQC?
Close quarters combat, huh?
Yeah!
I've been in green berets for the past few years.
I'm probably pretty rusty.
Not to worry.
I'll be here to help you remember.
After all, this is your first actual survival mission.
I'll be supporting you over the radio.
Where are you, boss?
Next to the Major?
The boss is communicating with us by radio from aboard a Permit Class submarine in the Arctic Ocean.
My frequency is 141.80.
Why is she in...
Why is she there?
Gotcha.
Your mission is to retrieve Dr. Sokolov.
Dr. Sokolov is being held in an abandoned factory located to the north of your current position.
Avoid heavy combat and don't let anyone see you.
Don't forget that this is a stealth mission.
Yeah.
Stealth mission.
She's going to shout out Shadow Moses.
Yeah, obviously.
The boss goes where the boss wants him.
Snake, try to remember some of the basics of CQC.
Yeah!
Say it.
Commencing virtuous mission now.
No!
Yeah!
Alrighty.
Pies decided to not talk anymore because she...
Come here, you stinky girl.
Hold on.
My cat.
Come here.
She was being so squeaky.
No, no, no, no!
Don't attack that!
Don't attack that.
What are you doing?
What are you doing, girl?
Come here.
Oh, she's like playing.
She'll like run up to me and then she'll start playing with the toy.
So she keeps getting distracted by the toy.
And not coming to me and not meowing.
Why are you looking at me?
What are you doing?
What are you doing, silly girl?
Come here.
Everybody wants to hear you.
I'm moving my mic.
Oh, yeah!
That was a squeak.
Yeah.
Oh, I just...
Oh my gosh, I just shocked her with my hand!
Hold on!
Oh no, she ran away!
Okay, hold on.
I'll be right back.
I'm gonna let her out.
Okie dokie.
Alright.
Now...
Commencing virtual mission now.
Kuwabara!
Not to my cat!
I didn't mean to shoot that.
My bad.
Okay, we got our little mic.
We got our knife.
I saw...
Oh, there he is.
Ah!
We gotta get a snack, you guys.
We gotta get a good ol' snack.
Oh!
Since we have some stuff, let's call...
We gotta call paramedic.
We gotta call the boss.
We gotta call people first, you know?
I see you've captured a giant anaconda.
A giant anaconda?
The giant anaconda is believed to be the largest snake in the world...
You're not gonna introduce yourself?
Or anything?
It's not poisonous, but its large size makes it extremely powerful.
They say it even eats crocodiles.
Crocodiles?
Its only natural predator is man.
And snake.
The giant anaconda is a very large snake.
You should be able to capture it alive using the tranquilizer gun.
Got it.
So how does it taste?
I knew you were going to ask me that.
Glad I didn't disappoint you.
So?
Well, the guide says it tastes alright.
Good.
I'll have to try some.
Ugh.
She's already sick of his antics.
Come on, paramedic.
What else you got?
I see you caught yourself a reticulated python.
We did get the reticulated python!
The reticulated python is said to be the longest snake in the world.
The biggest ones can grow up to 10 meters in length.
10 meters?
Although they're not poisonous, they're still very dangerous.
So be careful around them.
Okay.
They have a highly ferocious temperament, and they can swallow whole, even large animals like deer and pigs.
Their most distinguishing feature is the mesh pattern of their scales.
This pattern acts as a highly effective natural camouflage.
Codec 141.80.
Used by liquid.
Snake pretending to be Iroquois, and now used by the boss.
Coincidence?
No, I trust the boss.
It's a huge snake, but you should be able to capture it alive by using the tranquilizer gun.
Oh!
I'll bet if you capture one and throw it at an enemy, it'll give them a good scare.
Right.
But how do they taste?
Do they taste good?
You're actually going to eat one.
Why would I be asking?
What was that?
Nothing.
Let's see what the guide says.
Ah, you're in luck.
It says they taste pretty good.
Good.
I can hardly wait.
I forgot to mention you guys.
I forgot to mention so much.
Sorry, I got so excited about starting to mention this.
Try not to post spoilers in the chat.
Not for my sake, but for anybody who's watching and experiencing the series for the first time.
So I'll do my best also to refrain as much as I can.
But...
Not to say that that super chat was a spoiler or anything.
I think it's just an observation.
But...
Yeah, I'm gonna...
put this on, please.
No spoilers in chat.
And then we...
pin it.
There we go.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Just for people who are watching with us for the first time.
So, I appreciate your cooperation.
Camouflage is an indispensable tool when you're sneaking through the jungle.
To use camouflage, first press the start button to go to the survival view.
MasterBoss.
Then select camouflage.
And press the enter button.
Select a uniform to select battle fatigues.
And face to select face paint.
I am fatigued.
Yeah.
Choose battle fatigues that match the surrounding environment.
Now I'm going naked.
The most effective camouflage is attained by selecting fatigues that blend in with the environment.
Going with the tea.
Camouflage patterns that stand out in your surroundings will attract attention.
Yeah, I'm already fatigued.
Boss, I don't need any...
I don't need any more.
Going with the tea.
Let's see what camouflage we've got, baby.
Oh, there's a mask!
Yes!
Oh my gosh.
Woodland.
We'll go with woodland for now, right?
Uniform.
We got...
We'll do the tiger stripes.
It's plus 20 right now, you know?
If it releases 2024, MGS3 Delta or MGS3 for Delta Peace Walker?
I probably will play Delta once, like sooner than later.
Probably, you know, because it'll be it'll be just coming out.
I don't want, I will not want to wait most likely, so...
Yeah...
Oh yeah!
Another important thing.
The frog.
Look at the python!
Oh!
Anaconda!
Said to be so tasty.
But what about the tree frog?
I think the tree frog's kind of gross, probably.
Sorry, I know I'm catching up on I see you've caught a tree frog.
I'm catching up on Codex First.
The tree frog is a green frog that's found throughout Asia.
It's arboreal.
Spending most of its time in shrubs and bushes.
Use the tranquilizer gun to catch one alive.
I bet you could scare an enemy good if you tossed one out.
We're going to bring up the thermal goggles.
But the tree frogs that live in that jungle are a lot bigger than ordinary tree frogs.
I wouldn't want it any other way.
They've got an appetite, huh?
You've got a one-track mind, don't you?
But seriously, that is one theory.
I'm a simple man.
However, there are people who think it's a mutation caused by nuclear testing and waste from the research facility.
Do you think they're safe to eat?
Is that all you ever think about?
What is there?
Lots.
Like what?
Like why a frog would get so big in the first place.
Whether it's a temporary phenomenon More to eat!
created by a unique environment or a permanent mark of evolution or a product of the toxic waste coming out of the research facility.
If it is the waste that's causing it, He doesn't care about anything else.
then it means humans are interfering with the ecosystem.
It really makes you think about the changing relationship between This isn't interesting.
Oh, fine.
Be that way.
So, how about it?
You mean, is it edible?
Yeah.
Well, I guess it's probably okay.
Probably?
I don't know.
The guide doesn't say anything.
Pretty useless guide if you ask me.
Well, try one for dinner and you can help improve it.
Okay.
Snake, that area is inhabited by magpies.
Magpies?
Magpies are members of the crow family.
They're distinguishable by their beautiful dark blue and white bodies and their long tails.
Their favorite food is insects, but they'll also eat small fish, acorns, and fruit.
They're omnivores, which means they'll eat anything.
Right.
Just like you, huh?
If you use the tranquilizer gun, you should be able to capture magpies.
I mean, paramedic, you're quite the snack yourself.
Okay.
So how do they taste?
Kuwabara, kuwabara.
So?
I've never heard of anybody actually eating a magpie.
But I suppose there's no reason you couldn't.
You don't say.
Oh...
Why does she sound so disappointed in me?
Oh, why does she sound so disappointed?
Okie dokie.
Shall we continue onwards?
So I know what that one...
There are people complaining, right?
About the load times in between areas in Delta, right?
Um...
I think though...
Like, I think, you know...
Just to kind of like give my point of view a little bit on this.
Because, you know...
I don't know.
Anybody want to hear my opinion?
But um...
Essentially, there were people that were disappointed that the game wasn't more like open world.
People were like I hope that Delta is like a super accurate recreation to the original.
But then they're also just like...
They're also just like...
Wait, it's too faithful to the original!
Go back!
But also...
You know, it's kind of hard to tell Um...
But like...
Between here...
Between different areas...
Is like...
More stretch of land that they are like not including.
You know what I mean?
Like in certain parts of the maps as well.
So you would have to really redesign like a whole lot of the game, I think.
I feel like it's...
Um...
It would really break a lot of like how the game was played originally.
So, you know, I know that people are like kind of...
What's the word?
Divided, I suppose, between it?
But...
Like there are some sections that are like super duper far between sections.
So...
Is that a magpie?
I don't know.
I have no issue with it, to be honest.
I'm fine with being able to just have the load screens and everything.
Yeah!
Look at the little crocodiles!
They're so cute!
Look at them!
How do I zoom in again?
Zoom in with square.
Oh, triangle.
Wow, it's the slowest zoom.
Oh, there we go.
It's pressure sensitive.
Just kidding.
Look at that guy!
Oh!
There he goes!
Oh, I love animals.
Maybe that's why I like this one so much.
The motion D...
I forgot.
We don't have like...
I didn't forget, but we don't have like a real...
radar anymore or anything.
Let's...
Let's put these guys to sleep.
Actually, it doesn't matter if I put them to sleep or...
Well, goodnight.
Oh my gosh, there's a bird.
If I...
Can I run over here?
I think I can.
Right?
I'll make it.
Okay.
Here's me.
Yes, need that very much.
What else is in...
this area?
Goodnight.
He
didn't even touch you, you asshole!
I'm sinking?
No!
Don't leave me alone!
Leave me alone!
I'm not even bothering you!
God!
Was there anything else?
Oh, the beehive!
Wait, I can grab this, can I?
Uh...
Just keep running.
Just keep going.
Don't worry about the beast.
And see, there's fruit!
See the fruit up there too and everything?
Little fruits and stuff.
Ha-ha-ha-ha!
Ha-ha-ha!
Ha -ha -ha -ha!
Ah...
Let's see...
I don't want...
I don't want to waste my bullets to shoot it down.
So we'll just keep going.
Onwards!
Onwards.
This is what they call a gourmet walkthrough.
What's there?
Two of them.
Oh my god.
Maybe you should whisper.
Maybe we shouldn't talk so loud.
The Kremlin?
Stage whispers.
Oh, you're right.
I haven't heard that term in forever.
The success of the mission depends on how well you use your camouflage.
Change your camouflage by selecting camouflage from the survival viewer.
The uniform option lets you pick your uniform while the face option lets you change your face paint.
Choosing camouflage that blends in with your surroundings will help you conceal yourself more effectively.
Also, don't forget that anything that moves will stay in your jungle.
If you just stay and look around like an idiot, you're bound to be spotted.
But if you crawl instead, you should be able to sneak by without being noticed.
Wait.
He is standing right on top of them.
How is he doing that?
You can see how effective your camouflage is by looking at the camo index.
The camo index shows how well your camouflage plays in the swarming area.
Play naked!
The higher the value, the harder you are to spot, and vice-versa.
The key is to make yourself one with nature.
Going with the tea.
Keep that in mind as you go along, okay?
Okay.
Thanks, boss.
I can't believe she, like, that was the example she showed was...
Oh, wait.
Was me naked.
She was just like, by the way, Snake, you can be naked if you want.
I can't even look.
Anyway.
Our one viewer.
Spin!
Yes!
Spin, Snake!
Spin!
I hope you have nothing in your stomach, buddy!
I hope you have nothing in your stomach!
Spin!
Spin, spin, spin, spin!
It's so gross.
Anyway.
Good stuff.
Where are these guys again?
Oh!
There he is.
Number two.
Number one.
We can take this guy.
We can take him out.
I know we can.
I'll get him right there.
Right in the...
Oh, where are you walking?
Head!
And your friend?
Um...
Nowhere to be found.
Just put you there.
What you got for me?
Oh, thanks.
I'm gonna step all over your body real quick.
Don't mind me.
Don't mind me stepping on you.
Stepping on you.
You know.
Stepping...
Where is the other guy, actually?
Where'd he go?
Oh, there he is.
I'm sneaky.
I'm sneaking around.
Hey, guys.
CQC is circle, right?
Oh!
Ew!
What do you think is in there?
What are we saying about naked?
Thanks for the superchats, by the way.
Thank you, guys.
I'm not standing in the open.
Actually, I am.
Looked at my Arcade Vendor stock.
Notice MGS...
Arcade Machine isn't listed anymore.
You didn't have anything to do with that.
No!
I actually...
Seymour, I actually didn't get it.
But wouldn't it have been crazy?
Why are there squares?
I don't believe that.
Going naked.
They won't even notice a thing.
They won't even suspect me.
It's fine.
It's so okay.
Where did he go?
Oh, there he is.
Okay.
I think I can get him from down here.
From this far away.
Wait, I can't even see his head.
Just kidding.
Oh, where is he?
Are you coming this way?
Yeah, fly away.
Oh.
What's up here?
They call me.
They call me the snake of the trees.
Oh my god.
He looks like a madman up here.
He's like...
He looks so freaky.
Okay, drop.
Wait.
I'm all topsy turvy.
Which way was I going?
Uh...
Wait.
I just took out a man.
Which way was I...
I'm lost.
I thought...
Wait.
Oh!
This is the guy we just took out.
Just kidding.
I'm found.
Oh my god.
There's this guy right there.
The motion detector...
Senses no one.
The OG camera wouldn't treat me like that.
Yeah?
You think so?
Give me whatever you got.
A smoke G.
Wait.
I forgot to loot this guy too.
Give me what you got.
What do you got?
Wait.
More bullets.
I'll take it.
Upsy daisy.
Oh.
Nobody.
It's locked.
Huh?
Nobody.
What are you talking about?
Freak?
There's no shirtless man running around the jungles.
Huh?
What was that?
Oh my god.
His boobs are so big that they were like clipping into his...
Into his...
The rest of his body.
That's crazy.
That smile.
What a mischievous guy.
So funny.
You know...
I...
I'm so excited for Delta because one thing about...
Keratan!
You see him?
One thing about...
About...
What's the word?
Oh.
The 3DS one.
Is that you can crouch walk.
And it's so great.
I miss crouch walking.
So much.
I'm too much of a baby, you guys.
I'm gonna go back with...
I'm too much of a baby.
I'm gonna become a leaf.
I'm just a simple leaf.
I'm just a simple little shaken baby leaf.
Okay?
I'm just a little baby leaf.
I'm...
These guys, they come all the way back, don't they?
And then we can get the beehive?
Or does he run away with them?
I can't remember.
He's right under it.
Let's just take it down.
Are you kidding me?
Oh wait, that's not the beehive.
Oh shit.
What's the beehive?
Which one's the beehive?
There's nothing here.
Yeah, nothing here.
That was the fruit.
It looks so much like the beehive.
I do that like...
I think...
There it is.
Okay, there it is.
Wait, where...
Where is he?
Okay, he's right under it.
Well, kinda.
Also...
I hear something.
Huh?
Ah!
Oh.
Uh...
Okay.
Can you leave?
Can you get out of here?
Why
couldn't you just go?
Oh my gosh.
Snake.
Um...
On my...
Okay, so...
Not that this is an excuse or anything, but on my monitor, you guys see it way clear...
More clearly than I do because on my computer, it's like stretched and like ultra zoomed...
Like ultra...
Not ultra wide.
But you know what I mean?
And you guys are seeing like the real...
Like resolution that it's supposed to be at.
But I'm not playing through OBS.
So...
You know.
Okay.
Let's go.
Thank you, my shell.
Oh my gosh.
Scared me.
Oh, Kiritan!
I forgot.
I forgot to shoot him down.
Oh my god!
Please let go of me!
There's no need to run!
Because I'm, like...
Let's go!
Getting out of here, was I going to run?
Yes.
That's me.
You're not barrels, you're like...
Let's go.
Hmm...
Ugh...
All right.
We will go and then...
I feel like a soldier of the 20th century.
CQC is so awesome!
This must be where they're holding Sokolov.
Major, I've reached the abandoned factory where Sokolov is supposedly being held.
This place is a dump.
I can't see Sokolov from here.
The security is pretty tight.
There are sentries posted around the perimeter.
Oh my god, they're everywhere.
I wonder how many are inside.
Oh no!
This place is a dump!
Poor Sokolov.
Your objective, Sokolov, is inside the factory.
They should be holding him in a room in the northeast section.
Okay.
Northeast section.
Got it.
Be careful.
Your mission is to bring Sokolov back alive.
He must not be exposed to any kind of danger.
Do not approach Sokolov while in the alert phase.
Okay.
Right.
Oh, and one more thing, Snake.
You mean there's more?
No, it's just that when you get to Sokolov, I want you to tell him something from me.
Yeah?
And that is?
Sorry for being so late.
Is that all?
Yes.
Understood.
Beginning my approach to the target.
Sorry for being so late.
That's not the line.
You can't just take my homework, you know?
You can't just steal my line and make it your own and be like, yeah, this was my line all along.
Come on, Major.
Hold on.
Let's also talk.
I see you've got yourself a Baltic hornet's nest.
I do.
Baltic hornets are a variety of hornets that inhabit that area.
I haven't saved yet, so I probably should save.
I want to get the...
Inside the nest are...
Codex and everything, you know?
Larvae, pupa, and adults.
You can eat them all.
You're waiting, innit?
In particular, the honey you find inside the nest is delicious and full of nutrients.
Nutrients.
It's easy to digest and helps pep you up when you're feeling tired.
In short, it's the perfect survival food.
Honey can also be used as a...
Honey.
Oh my gosh.
When she says it like that...
It creates a protective coating over the skin.
When you knock down a hornet's nest...
Kind of makes me flustered a little bit, you know?
A burn element will appear along with it.
Of course, the hornets aren't going to give up their nest without a fight.
If you knock a nest down, a large swarm of hornets will come flying out.
So be careful.
Yeah.
But we were fine.
We didn't get stung or anything.
We're a-okay.
Saving the game, Snake?
Yeah.
Are you going to stream the remake, Mint?
Of course not!
My gosh.
No, I'm just kidding.
Why would you ask me such a thing?
I'm just kidding.
I'll stream the remake once it goes out.
Save successful!
2099.
Hey, Snake.
You ever heard of Godzilla King of Monsters?
It begins.
No.
What is it?
It's a movie.
You haven't seen it?
Oh my gosh!
Godzilla!
It's about this monster...
Oh my gosh!
He goes to an enormous nuclear test...
He's just there!
And goes on a rampage in Tokyo.
Nuclear test, huh?
Yeah.
Then the Marshall Islands must be crawling with giant monsters right about now.
It's just make-believe.
Maybe that's why my pants have been so tight lately.
What?
Snake, it's a movie.
Not a report out of Los Alamos.
I know.
So then what happened?
Godzilla is immune to all weapons, and humanity has no way to stop monsters.
I still don't understand.
Dr. Serizawa develops a new type of weapon.
But meanwhile, Godzilla's getting...
I still don't understand.
The first time I saw it, I didn't understand it.
Look at that.
I still don't understand.
It was originally a giant monster.
It was a Japanese movie.
But they made an American version, too.
I recommend seeing the original Japanese one if you ever get the chance.
It's mostly mindless fun, but it's also got a serious anti-nuke message as well.
Where can I see the original?
You'll just have to go to Japan.
Really?
That's too bad.
You'll just have to go to Japan?
And if you wait 40 years, you might be able to see it in America, too.
Why's that?
2004 will be Godzilla's 50th birthday.
I don't want to think about it!
You think they're still going to be making Godzilla movies?
I want to pretend I don't know!
Of course.
I don't know.
I want to pretend!
I don't know!
I'm sure you know a lot about movies.
I don't suppose you're the movie-watching type, are you?
Not really.
Okay, then I'll tell you everything I know.
When the going gets tough, movies can save your life.
It's always good to be able to look at things from a different perspective when you get in a jam.
A jam.
That's the magic of movies.
No kidding.
Well, I guess it might at least make a nice distraction.
That's the spirit snake.
And video games.
Have a little fun.
She says.
Okay, you get out here, then.
Why is everybody we always talk to on the codec, they're just like so nonchalant about everything.
It's like, okay, well, you get your ass out here on the field, then.
They're just like, oh, come on.
Just do it.
Just take it easy.
Take a chill pill.
And you're just like, maybe.
You should be the one out here.
I'm just saying.
Just have fun.
Have fun.
You should be so...
It's that one Mei Ling line that's just like, you should be grateful that you're able to have enough free time to play video games.
Oh, it's so good.
What else is paramount?
I see you've found a Yabloko Moloko.
Yabloko.
What now?
Yabloko Moloko.
It's a Russian name that roughly translates as milk apple.
I think Matara said...
It's a type of star apple.
I can't remember if she said that was accurate or not.
It tastes as thick and sweet, like milk.
Hence the name.
Yabloko Moloko.
Yabloko.
And if you cut one in half lengthwise...
You'll see a star shaped ring radiating out from the center.
Wow.
Hence the star apple.
Right.
The star shaped part has a gelatinous texture and a set to be especially tasty.
Sounds useful.
You're welcome.
For once.
Did you say something?
No.
Back to the mission.
Oh wait.
She messaged me about something.
Actually I just got up.
So I'm gonna respond to her.
I
can start signing.
Yeah.
Also...
What is it?
Yabloko?
Maboko.
Oh, mabloko.
Shit.
Wait.
Wait, some people are saying...
Maloko.
Wait, what did you say?
Moloko.
Oh, hold on.
Shit, hold on.
Mo...
Moloko.
Yabloko moloko.
Apologies about earlier.
Don't apologize.
All good.
You notice how certain people keep certain codes.
No, no, no.
Like I said, you didn't...
You just...
You...
Sent an observation.
But it reminded me about the spoilers.
So, no.
Anything, I'm grateful.
Yours is just an observation.
It was about the codec stuff.
What did...
What did I say?
Oh, okay, nevermind.
Okay.
Let's continue onward.
I don't know if Matara will respond to me.
But if she does...
Yabloko.
I think they'll notice me here.
How many guards are there?
Did you see that?
That looked really cool.
That was like a spy movie, wasn't it?
That was pretty...
That was pretty intense.
That was pretty cool, if I say so myself.
If I just run up to every single guy and CQC them, I should be fine.
Parkour.
I need to get this guy.
Dang it.
Oh, I don't want him to get...
I don't...
I don't want to get him when he's like out in the open.
Wait, did he see me?
No.
Okay, just kidding.
I'm like 90 percent.
Arigato, arigato.
Chuuu.
Thank you.
You know what?
Screw it.
Let's just grab him.
Grab him and take him away.
Into the bushes.
Into the bushes you go.
No one will even notice you there.
Yeah.
Headshot.
Now we know how to get to him.
Sorry, I'm a camouflage kind of gal, you know.
I know there's...
I think there's one guy over there, is there not?
Oh, it's so nerve-wracking not having anything to tell.
But this guy is like so out in the open, I want to grab him.
Okay, let's just go for it.
Yaboko, Yaboko.
Yaboko, Yaboko, Yaboko, Yaboko.
You only Yaboko once.
Chaaaaaaaav!
Let's go.
Finish him?
I'm a pacifist, what are you talking about?
So, I've been like watching...
Like some speedrun stuff.
I just don't have the confidence to do it.
Maybe off stream I'll like...
Maybe off stream I'll like try doing some stuff and seeing what I can...
What I can accomplish, you know?
There's that hole over there, but we need to get in right there.
Let's see, I don't remember how many guys are in here.
Yeah.
That's that snake, isn't it?
Right there in the bushes.
Pretty sure that's what that's detecting.
I can't tell!
Play it for fun.
Yeah.
I'm not trying to be speedrunner.
I'm just saying.
I want to...
There's like really fun ways that you can mess with the guards.
And I want to like...
Like one thing that I for sure know...
Sorry, I keep crouching because I'm like talking.
But I see that guy.
I saw him over there.
Is utilizing the magazines more is one thing that I really want to do.
Like the dirty... the porn magazines.
I want to utilize those more.
Which sounds...
Sorry, that sounds kind of...
Sounds kind of...
But...
But they're so useful!
They're so useful!
I'm not trying to...
Not from...
I'm not...
I want...
I'm not using them.
But like the guards...
You know?
I'm just saying.
The thin books.
I own a lot of those.
I'm just saying!
Whatever you say, boy.
Stop!
You guys believe me!
Believe me!
I'm afraid.
This game gives me indigestion.
Oh my gosh.
Can't see anything.
Oh, hi snake.
These other guys are going to wake up eventually.
So I probably should like...
Actually get moving.
Oh my gosh.
Oh no.
Nothing?
Oh my gosh.
Where is that guy?
That's like...
Oh, there it is.
There he is.
Oh my gosh.
I can get him.
Maybe if I just shoot...
Maybe I lure him...
Lure...
Lure him out!
That guy is going to get bit by the snake.
He's going to die probably.
Come on!
And I'm so sorry!
There it is.
Fine.
Wait.
How did they hear me?
I'm actually confused.
Oh!
Wait!
Did someone wake up?
Oh no!
Oh shoot.
Who's...
Maybe I should just go for it.
I can't tell who saw me.
They have good ears.
Okay, hold on.
Isn't there stuff in here anyway?
Besides rats.
Oh my gosh.
Just a whole ass snake.
A little rat.
Are you just gonna eat that?
No one heard that?
Oh, they're here in my stomach though!
They're gonna hear my stomach.
Let's eat.
The tree frog is nasty.
But I think we should eat it first.
It'll go bad.
Eat.
Disgusting.
The reticulated python?
Good.
Tasty.
Yeah.
This is our...
This is not...
That's a different area.
Is there anything else in here?
More snake.
Are the rats tasty?
I wonder.
I don't know who heard me!
I'm still so confused.
Rat!
What's that sound?
He heard me going...
The rat.
He heard me go...
I know!
Idiot!
Oh my gosh.
The caution music is so good though, right?
Yeah, there's nothing here, bozo.
I hear him walking.
Okay.
Actually, I feel like I'm in a worse spot than I was before.
I feel like I'm in a worse spot than I was before.
You guys love the rats.
How do I get out?
I don't remember where they're at.
If I leave here...
Oh my gosh, I hear him walking.
He's like right there.
Okay, I'm gonna leave.
We're gonna...
There's a guy here.
I could probably get him in the legs, you know?
At least.
Never mind.
Hold on, we could go...
Get out of here!
I wish
we could go in through here.
I wish we could go in through here.
I wish we could get out of here.
Sorry, Sokolov.
No!
I just caused the caution again!
Nooo!
Noo!
It was supposed to go through the hole!
You son...
There.
Well, it did go through the hole.
My suppressor is still on, so I'm confused why they keep hearing us.
What's wrong?
Oh, dang it.
I can't...
Oh, well that was such a waste then.
Do you think they'll hear it?
You think they'll hear it this time?
That was through the hole.
Can you guys leave, please?
Leave me alone.
They're so mean to me, you guys.
They're so mean to me.
I can't even... I can't even leave.
They're too obsessed with me.
Oh my god.
Keep walking.
What's wrong?
What's going on?
Shit.
You guys were in a bit of a loop.
Guys.
What's wrong?
Oh no.
There's so many guys.
Nothing's wrong.
Go away.
What's wrong?
The timer just keeps resetting.
This sucks.
What's wrong?
Everybody is dropping.
They're dropping like flies.
Everything is wrong.
Everything is wrong, apparently.
Oh my god.
Can you leave?
I should have never entered this hole.
The hole is a trap, you guys.
The hole is a trap.
What's wrong?
Okay.
Caution.
Caution over.
We're going to...
Gun is ablazing.
We're going to see if you see the guy up above in this hole.
Up above here, we're going to take him down.
And we're going to go to Sokolov.
Probably what I should have just done.
Should have just gone, gone fists ablazing.
But you know...
You die and learn, okay?
Kero-tan!
I see him!
I see him, Kero-tan!
There's a Kero-tan in each area.
Is there a Kero-tan in the first first area?
Wait, I missed two then already.
So, what's wrong?
What's wrong?
So, I missed two already.
So...
No point in getting all... or trying for them, you know?
Do you get a reward for finding them all?
You do, actually!
If you find them and shoot them all, yeah.
What's wrong?
You guys, is this the... is this the peak Metal Gear Solid gameplay you expected of me?
Oh my gosh.
Minto loves Metal Gear Solid.
She's gonna be really good at that game.
Five hours of crawling.
The Major is probably just like, what is he doing?
Why won't he leave?
What's wrong?
I know.
I know we're on a time limit.
I'm just...
You know.
Sokolov can wait.
This guy, he's really alert.
Patrol here.
Unable to locate the problem.
Understood.
Return to your position.
Yeah.
Okay.
Thank you, my show.
I'm gonna be brave.
You can...
You can CQC while holding the gun, right?
Like, that's part of the whole thing.
Like, you can CQC and hold the gun.
Right?
I specifically said, and you know, she's...
She what?
She's stayed polished.
What does that mean?
Now everybody's awake.
Which is really great.
Really happy about that.
Oh my gosh.
We see the sunlight.
Oh my god.
What's wrong?
Are you kidding me?
Oh
my god.
Clash of the Gods.
Who is the Clash of the Gods?
Let them leave me alone.
Oh, there's two of them.
Does this guy come over here?
I can't remember.
Hold on.
I remember something.
Oh my god.
I can't.
When will anybody ask me what's right?
I'm sick of asking what's wrong.
I'm sick of asking.
This is what I remembered.
That I can come up here.
And take them down from the ceiling.
Oh.
Wait, where'd they go?
If I can see them.
Well, uh...
What's wrong?
Everybody says, what's wrong?
Wasn't there another guy over here?
Oh, wait.
Huh?
Are?
That's him.
Oh.
They're just standing there menacingly.
If I drop down...
Wait, is it...
Oh, they're both there.
Okay, I see them.
Do they not hear my footsteps?
Can you move?
Can you, like...
I can't...
I can't hit you from this angle.
Maybe I can?
Oh.
Maybe I can.
But the other guy...
Oh, I can.
Oh my god.
Can we...
There we go.
Yeah!
I am stronger!
Okay, Snake.
This is not time for Cirque du Soleil.
Thank you.
Oh.
Sokodev!
Give me a second.
I'm gonna take their stuff.
See ya.
Again, like I said, guys.
The hole...
That was my demonstration of showing you that the hole is a trap.
You feel safe in there, but you really aren't.
Don't go into the hole.
Okay?
Anyways.
Thanks for the demonstration.
You're so welcome!
The hole is not the goal.
Sokodev!
Avoid the hole!
It's a non-glorious hole.
Just like the Virtuous Mission.
What is this?
No!
We'll never know.
He threw it away.
You must be Sokolov.
Are you one of Vulcan's men?
Oh.
Kuwabara.
You'll never get it from me.
No.
I'm a CIA agent.
Yeah.
Can't you tell?
I've come to escort you back to the other side of the Iron Curtain.
That's my hole.
It was made for me.
No!
You're all CIA.
Yeah.
I was sent by Major Zero.
The man who got you out two years ago.
Tell him what he said.
He said...
Kept you waiting, huh?
Zero.
I have a message from him.
What is it?
He said to tell you, sorry for being so late.
Did he now?
What is it?
What does it mean?
He said...
It means he's a man of his word.
Ah.
But we've got no time for this.
You have to get me out of here before they arrive.
Who's they?
Colonel Vulgin of Groove.
Groove?
You in the West know him as Thunderbolt.
That's that guy from Minions.
Never heard of him.
He's a member of the Iron Curtain.
Real footage.
And they're both.
Oh my god!
That already happened!
It means he cut the line.
Oh my gosh!
There he is!
Colonel Vulcan!
Oh my god!
Oh my gosh.
That guy.
He looks like... a freak.
The intelligence says that they are going to make their move during the test.
Have I seen the secret leader?
I have!
But it's on a different disc.
Exactly.
They wouldn't need that many men just to keep me inside.
Their orders were to prevent Colonel Vulcan from capturing me.
Even if it meant killing me in the process.
Or so it would seem.
So it would seem.
I hope Delta has secret leader.
Me too!
I hope so too.
Oh my gosh.
The cutscenes.
The secret leader cutscenes in high def will be...
Too much.
I should have changed to naked.
Oh.
Russian Jozu.
Where did you learn to speak it?
From my mentor.
Is that so?
Oh snake.
Oh my gosh.
I've seen your face again.
America is truly a frightening country.
Having second thoughts?
No.
I have no love for this place.
Let's go.
Dang.
I feel like with Sokolov's jacket, it looks like one of those that would squeak at every time he moves.
We're trying to do a stealth mission and this guy is in full on leather.
He takes two steps and it's like Spongebob.
Sokolov is safe with me.
He's doing fine.
No injuries.
Good work, Snake.
Now hurry up and get Sokolov to the recovery point.
We'll rendezvous with you there.
Rendezvous.
What about the sentries?
No one spotted me.
I see.
The Fonz jacket.
We lost contact with the boss some time ago.
What happened?
Uh oh.
It's probably just a weak signal.
Just hurry and get Sokolov out of there.
Okay.
No.
The boss.
It's because she's too deep in the sauce.
Submarine sauce.
Okay.
Alright.
Quiet, Sokolov.
Quiet.
Oh my god.
I'm not... you guys.
Oh god.
Okay, you guys.
I'm not...
You guys, my heart is not...
You guys, I'm not ready, I think.
I don't think I'm ready.
I don't think I'm ready right now.
You guys, I don't think I'm ready.
What is this position?
What is this stance, Sokolov?
He's trying to be like me.
He's like Kamehameha-ing.
Oh gosh.
I'm so ready.
I'm so...
I'm not ready.
I'm not normal.
I'm not...
Ah!
Oh gosh.
I'm not normal.
I thought I'd be normal.
Freeze!
Oh my gosh.
They got us so fast.
So this is the legendary boss.
You made it last.
Oh my god.
You.
You're from the Ocelot unit of Spetsnaz.
What's a Gru soldier doing here?
That's my reaction.
Oh my god.
Soldier?
Who's the Ocelot commander?
That's Major Ocelot to you.
Oh my g...
Don't you forget.
No!
Sokolov is ours.
Now get out of here.
And Ocelot never lets his prey escape.
Oh my god.
My...
What?
Ocelot will get you.
Oh my gosh.
My bratty little...
Oh my god.
No.
I'm not ready for it to happen right now.
You got...
Oh guys.
I'm gonna cry.
Get him.
He's up there.
No.
I'm not ready.
I'm not ready for them to touch.
I can't.
No.
I can't say it feels good to kill a comrade.
Even if it is for the Gru.
Sokolov, take cover.
He's wanting a hug.
Oh my gosh.
I'm getting a stomach ache.
I'm so excited.
Why does he look at him like that?
Stop.
You're not the boss, are you?
Stop, you freak.
Freak meet freak.
I can't.
What is that stance?
That gun.
Oh my god.
Everybody laugh.
You're not the boss.
Oh my gosh.
Then die.
Idiot.
Oh my god.
This one.
Shut
up.
Shut up.
Leave it.
Shoot the other one.
Wow.
So awesome.
What is that one guy who's like in the background?
He's really losing it.
You get tranked, little guy.
Shaggy.
Is that an Ocelot emoji?
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no, no.
I love CQC, baby.
Oh my god.
Say it.
Tell him everything he's doing, Roxnake.
Possible.
Oh my god.
You ejected the first bullet by hand, didn't you?
He's like, the way he's like wriggling on the ground.
But to testing a technique you only heard about in the middle of battle wasn't very smart.
You were asking to have your gun jammed on you.
Dun dun.
Besides, I don't think you're cut out for an automatic in the first place.
Oh my god.
He's sitting with like a halo around him.
It's like a true Little Mermaid moment.
That's more of a revolver technique.
You filthy American dog!
Just keeps getting his ass handed to him.
But that was some fancy shooting.
You're pretty good.
Pretty... good.
I can't look.
I absolutely cannot look.
I cannot look.
I cannot see.
I cannot see this.
I can't hear.
I can't watch them.
That was the moment.
That was the moment his life changed.
I have to go to the bathroom.
Snake, you alright?
Dog!
Three most romantic words ever said.
Oh my gosh.
That moment literally rewired his brain.
Oh gosh.
It's the most romantic thing ever.
I love that moment!
It rewired your brain.
Absolutely.
Oh my god.
Little sleepy boy.
Yeah, you sleep down there.
You sleep...
Look at his hands.
So funny.
What's with that stance?
Okay, I gotta go to the bathroom real quick.
I'll be right back.
Wait, but these guys... they don't wake up.
I'm taking him with me.
Come on Bracelot.
We're going home.
Mousetrap!
Okay, I do actually have to pee though.
So I'll be right back.
Just gotta go to the bathroom real quick.
B.R.V.
Ya bloco maloco.
Oh my gosh.
I...
Um...
Didn't put...
I ran out of toilet paper.
And didn't put it in the closet.
In the bathroom.
So I had to...
I had to...
I had to run pantsless to go and get it.
Oh my gosh.
I have to...
Holy cow.
Thank you Johnny Moe.
Thank
you so much!
What the heck!
Thank you!
How...how...how...how...how...
I don't have anything.
Did I grab everything?
In this area as well?
Where was Kero-tan?
We saw him from...
That hole.
I actually don't see him here.
Oh there he is.
Oh my god.
Please!
You're walling!
For real!
For realist!
For the realist!
Realist!
Thank you!
But seriously!
Oh my gosh.
Please.
It's okay.
Thank you but please!
Thank you so much!
Oh my gosh.
Why so many?
I really shouldn't have had coffee and like...
Watch that scene.
It just made like the coffee...
You know like...
It just went...
I was just like...
It's forced the liquid out of my body.
I was like...
I have to pee now.
Is there anything else here?
I don't remember.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Thank you!
Too much!
Is your wallet okay for real though?
Do
you want to save?
The only freak I saw during that cutscene was the bottom right.
Stop.
Who was in the bottom right?
It was...
Ocelot.
You're welcome.
Stop.
Why does it say 2099?
Because my PS2 clock is wrong.
It's a lot more intense, but...
It wouldn't be referring to you coming from outer space, would it?
How rude!
Why do you say that?
Because no one on Earth could be as charming as you.
Sorry, I'll just get to the point, Snake.
Be careful of what's around you when you're in the water.
Just imagining you swimming in those jungle rivers makes me think of you being attacked by a fishman.
A fishman?
Snake is so... smooth.
Fishmen aren't the only things that will attack you in the water.
Really be careful out there.
Okay.
And don't be attacking any pretty girls going for a swim, either.
Are you calling me a fishman?
You started it.
Fishmen.
She really isn't responding.
Oh wait, where do I go for Sokolov again here?
I can't... I don't remember.
Snake, stay alert.
The KGB and Gru both have their sights set on Sokolov.
Gru is a military espionage outfit.
The intelligence wing of the Soviet Defense Ministry's General Staff Office.
It competes with the KGB, which is under the Ministry of Internal Affairs, and the two are always watching each other.
Never let the left hand know what the right hand is doing.
Exactly.
Yes.
Now, added to that rivalry, there's a vicious power struggle going on between the Khrushchev faction and the anti-Khrushchev faction.
Thanks for the super chat.
Lambda, please!
And Volgin and the anti-Khrushchev forces are using the grunt.
That's the idea.
What's happening?
The two factions are fighting over Sokolov.
We're in an extremely dangerous situation here.
Yeah, I'm aware of that.
Get Sokolov out of there safely.
He must not be turned over to the KGB or to the Gru.
He must be turned over to my arms.
Sokolov took off in the direction of the rope bridge.
Get after him.
Hurry!
Oh, the rope bridge.
Oh, yes.
How could I forget?
Okay, yes, of course.
I was getting ahead of myself with that exit.
Hahaha.
Go!
Sokolov!
Oh, wait.
I'm taking you with me.
Come on.
This way.
Bro has the philosopher's legacy.
Hahaha.
Okay.
I'm legitimately concerned.
Thank you.
Okay, here we go.
Ocelot's coming with.
Don't leave him behind, Snake.
You better drag him with us.
No!
Why did you leave him?
Do you guys hear a storm approaching?
Okay.
Those men were from the ocelot unit.
Spetsnaz?
Yes.
The best crew has to offer.
They're coming for me.
I'm finished.
Calm down.
I'll get you out of here.
I promise.
And we've got some of the best backup we could ask for.
Uh-oh.
What is that thing?
That's what they were making you build.
Yes.
The Shagahod.
A treading behemoth.
A tank capable of launching nuclear weapons.
Dry RPMs.
It can launch nuclear missiles from that kind of terrain?
Oh, yes.
And without support from friendly units.
A nuclear-equipped tank capable of operating solo.
Wow!
Is that thing finished?
No.
This is only the end of Phase One.
It won't be truly finished until we complete Phase Two.
Phase Two.
What's next?
The weapons truly fall.
One.
Two.
What comes after one?
If it is completed, the colonel gets his hands on it.
Phase Two.
It will be the end of the Cold War.
The end of the Cold War.
Thank you for the gift, dude.
Yes.
And then the age of fear will truly begin.
Thank you for the gift, dude.
Oh, no!
The guy had no choice but to cooperate.
I didn't want to die.
I wanted to see my wife and child again.
In America.
Please.
Take me to America.
Quickly.
They cannot complete it without my help.
Yeah.
Got it.
Let's go.
Yeah.
We're on our way.
Come on.
Let's go.
Okay.
Here we go.
All right.
To America.
We just got to get... Okay.
Be careful on this bridge, Sokolov.
I slipped off of it earlier.
Yeah.
Do you hear thunder?
No.
Oh, my gosh.
Take off that squeaky...
Yeah.
Don't look.
Don't look down.
Freaky.
Ooh.
Starting to get pretty misty.
Whoa.
I get misty.
The moment you're near.
What was that?
Huh?
Who is that?
Boss.
The boss.
Oh, my gosh.
Another 50.
Thank you.
Boss.
Please.
I'm really concerned though.
Good work, Jack.
Yeah?
What are you doing here?
Sokolov comes with me.
Oh.
Wait.
You were supposed to be in the Arctic.
How did you get here so fast?
Oh.
Oh, no.
Not the bees.
Ow.
Oh, my God.
Sokolov.
Look.
He's petting those bees.
Not the bees.
Snake is so calm about this.
He's just like, well, shucks.
Yeah.
My friends.
Let us fight together again.
My NAKAMA.
His voice is so funny.
We will fight with you.
Oh my god.
My favorite bosses!
I love cover unit!
It's raining.
It's raining blood.
Oh, it's raining blood.
Sorry, I should have been more specific.
Is he crying?
The sorrow.
Thank you.
Leo Red!
Kuwabara!
Oh my gosh, you guys are here witnessing.
Sorry, I'm really brain rotted.
I'm so sorry.
Ah, what a joyful scene.
You guys missed me with Ocelot though, so maybe it's okay.
Welcome to my country.
And to my unit.
I love Vulcan, even though he's such a bastard.
Boss, what is this?
I'm defecting to the Soviet Union.
Sokolov is a little gift for my new hosts.
Recoilless nuclear warheads.
Recoilless?
It's crazy that Vulcan is a fan of yours.
Kuwabara, kuwabara.
Who is he?
Another one of your disciples?
What do you mean another one?
I'm THE disciple.
Are we taking him with us?
Thanks for the gift.
Best sadness.
Too pure for us cobras.
I'm just a baby.
Just a baby.
He has not yet found an emotion to carry into battle.
What are you talking about?
Do you think you can pull the trigger?
Rookie's eyes.
She takes apart my whole gun in one move.
It's insane.
She's so awesome.
The boss is so cool.
Sorry.
I don't like seeing him in pain.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
We can't let him live.
No!
Kuwabara, kuwabara.
If Khrushchev finds out about this, we're finished.
He
must die.
No!
Wait.
He's my apprentice.
I'll take care of him.
Jack.
You can't come with us.
You can't sit with us.
Why are you extending a hand?
Come on.
Come on, mom.
Don't do this to me.
What did you think was going to happen?
What's going to happen?
He's so...
His eyes darting everywhere.
It's so sad.
He's so like...
He took her bandana.
He's like...
He's so...
Sorry.
The grunts are so...
Does anyone else just randomly do the hater grunt while driving?
The new blood has been rejected.
I do the hater grunt all the time.
I just go...
No!
Snake!
Are we done here?
Now onto Sokolov's research...
He looks so confused.
During this whole exchange.
It's so sad.
It's so sad for him.
Seriously.
The way he grunts.
My place is with them now.
No!
Boys!
He's like...
He wants to sound like a Great Dane.
But he just reminds me of a Chihuahua.
You know?
Just because it's always like a...
Like, you know...
When Simba's trying to growl in the Lion King.
That's what it's like.
Oh my gosh.
I've given up.
I've given up on your wallet.
I think you have too.
But thank you.
I just can't only say thank you.
But please be responsible.
For their money.
Snake's alive.
Snake,
can you hear me?
Yeah.
Just barely.
Snake, listen to me.
You need emergency medical treatment.
Can you move?
Snake!
You've got to get those wounds treated.
Hang in there.
Alright, let's get you fixed up.
Paramedic?
Okay, Snake.
Just relax and it'll all be over before you know it.
Oh my gosh, she's gonna kill me.
Snake!
Stay with me.
I've seen people in worse shape before.
Think you can handle it?
Major.
The boss.
She's defected.
That's all he cares about.
First we've got to get you patched up.
Here we go.
Oh, gosh, open the menu.
First open the survival viewer with the start button.
Ohh, no.
If you select Cure you can start the treatment.
Healing is divided into treatment using medicine with the item window button Yes.
and surgical treatment using the weapon window button.
Yes.
Your injuries include a fractured left elbow or rib bone and lacerations on your upper arms, right elbow and abdomen.
They need to be fixed using surgical treatment.
No.
H Situation is at risk.
Risking a guy in that much pain to do surgery on himself is pretty insane.
It's kind of insane.
Use the left analog stick to select the medical item and then press the enter button.
Yes.
With this method you can use items to help your recovery process.
To treat a bone fracture, first secure the affected area with a fastener and then wrap it in bandages.
That should do it.
Not the bone fracture.
It's crazy.
For lacerations, you'll need disinfectant to clean the wound, sutures to stitch it up, styptic to slow the flow of blood, and bandages to wrap the wound.
If you do everything I mentioned, the wound should heal completely.
Understood?
Yeah.
Stay with me.
Go into the survival view and treat the wound.
Okay.
I'm going into the menu!
Cure!
Oh, we're like losing life fast fast.
Okay.
Alright.
Cure!
Ooh!
Okay.
Alright.
Suffering from a deep cut.
Bleeding.
No bandage applied.
Not yet disinfected.
So we gotta...
We gotta surgically disinfect.
Disinfect.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
What about the other ones?
No bone fracture.
Disinfect.
Disinfect to protect.
Okay.
No more disinfect.
Next we do...
Do we have to suture?
Wait.
Suture?
Oh.
Wait.
Was this one a cut?
Yeah.
Suture.
Broken bone.
You know.
We just got broken bones.
Whatever.
Broken bone.
A cut.
Suture.
Okay.
Alright.
Um.
I love this.
The bones...
Just put a band-aid on it.
Gosh.
All you have to do is just...
Easy.
Um.
Oh.
And the splint.
Yay!
Um.
Just put a band-aid on it.
Just put a...
Just put a band-aid.
Easy.
Band-aid?
What did I forget here?
Wait.
I'm still bleeding.
What am I reading?
What did I forget?
Ointment?
No, for burns.
It's the styptic?
Yeah!
Okay, okay.
There we go.
Yay!
Okay, okay.
Styptic.
And then...
Bandage, right?
Yeah.
Okay!
Okey-dokey.
We're all good.
I don't like this.
Oh gosh.
Oh gosh, it hurts so bad.
Ugh.
I'm an empath, you guys.
Oh my gosh.
How do you...
How are you gonna look after this?
In Delta, I wonder.
They're like, All wounds stay on your body!
I mean, I know these are like...
scripted wounds, so I wonder.
Oh...
Snake!
Oh, the bandana!
Oh my gosh, what have I done?
Thank you!
Good job, Snake.
We're coming to get you now.
Just stay where you are.
We'll drop a recovery balloon.
Fulton Meow!
Can you set it up?
Also, Pepman, I...
just saw your...
dono...
um...
about gifts outside of a convention.
I don't actually...
Oh wait.
Hold on.
We just barely saw him.
I don't actually have a way, but maybe in the future.
But thank you for thinking of me.
I really appreciate it.
A body.
Did you see the skelly?
The shagohod.
His arms are droopy.
He's like when you pick up a cat and his arms just like spread out.
Papers!
Scissors!
Always go rock.
Little droopy shagohod.
He's like put me down!
Put me down mom!
Come on!
Put me down!
Oh no.
Here's where it all really begins.
Oh my gosh.
This guy is...
He is so...
I can't!
He's sitting there just pondering all his life choices.
He's like what the hell?
He's actually seething.
For real.
Thanks to the boss and her cobras, I have both Sokolov and the shagohod.
Stinky woman.
Girl smell?
God, this guy is such a freak.
What are we going to do with the girl?
Who is she?
Apparently she's Sokolov's woman.
Sokolov!
You dog!
How did you manage to grab such a babe?
Not her scooting away.
She's a nice catch.
Yeah.
I'll take her.
I'll take her?
Not so fast, my dear.
Finders keepers.
The other three are not so much as fakers.
It's just lipstick.
A kiss of death.
You KGB.
We may be able to use her.
She has spunk.
Ooh!
The way she's like not even making any sort of sound.
Everyone in this game is a freak.
I think maybe that's why I love it so much.
Uh-oh!
But it won't be me that pulled the trigger.
It'll be our friend, the American defector.
You're going to nuke your fellow Russians?
This is where the...
Remember the Alamo.
Ah!
Remember the Alamo!
Remember the Alamo.
Oh man.
Oh my gosh, in that one moment, he looks like that meme.
A minor spelling mistake.
For just a split second, he looked like that meme.
Minor spelling mistake.
Oh gosh.
Let's save, yes.
Sorry, my PlayStation's clock is off.
If you couldn't tell.
I realize, because my clock is off and is kind of weird...
I will probably...
I'll have to, like, be very careful about when...
About when I do the end fight.
Yeah!
Then I'll bite off!
But you're so supreme Ba-ba-da-ba-da Ooh,
snake eater In my time There'll be no one else
Crying is the way I'm flying to you I'm still in a dream Snake eater
Someday you go through the rain And someday you feed on a tree frog It's ordeal, the trial to survive I'm still in a dream For the day we see new light I give my life Ooh,
snake eater In my time There'll be no one else
Crying is the way I'm flying to you
I'm still in a dream Snake eater
Ba -ba-da-ba-da I'm still in a dream Snake eater Snake, snake, snake Snake, snake, snake Snake, snake, snake In the dream
There's a plane Doing out the window On a ice cube I'll make you Become my guide By landing on the same platform In this peomnia As the cause of our family Drone oil pressure and voltage are nominal.
Such a great, amazing song.
Halo oxygen supply is nominal.
Thank you for the super!
Thank you!
No gusts.
All systems go for drone detachment.
Snake, we can't risk a Halo jump this time around.
Airspace security has gotten tighter since we were last here.
Okay.
We can't get as close to the ground as we did during the Virtuous mission.
So instead, we'll be using one of our newest weapons.
Snake, you're being given an honor on par with Alan Shepard.
This is our last chance.
Show your patriotism.
If you fail, you'll be back in a hospital bed again waiting for the firing squad.
That's not right!
Okay, what's it like if I failed?
What if there's ex- Then maybe you should be sending a whole team in!
Would you do me a favor and tell the suits about visiting hours?
I'll never get better with them assaulting me day and night with their questions.
Must be part of the top brass' inquiry.
More like an interrogation.
According to them, I'm a traitor and an accomplice to the boss' defection.
They're just looking for a scapegoat.
Does that mean they're after you, too?
Let's just say neither one of us is going to be made a national hero out of this.
Does this mean Fox is going to die?
No.
This Fox is still one step ahead of the house.
The reason I came to see you today... Jack?
I'm a scapegoat.
I'm a scape- A snake!
What are you talking about?
The situation has changed.
We've still got a chance to come out of this one alive.
Yeah?
What kind of chance?
Don't get too excited.
Here.
Have a cigar.
It's Cuban.
Whoa!
Oh my gosh.
Major disappeared.
He's a ghost.
Oh my gosh, look at him.
He's... he's glitching around.
This morning, I had a meeting with the CIA.
They decided when they're going to execute us?
No.
Something even bigger.
Bigger?
Yesterday, the White House received an unexpected call.
From?
President Johnson.
Oh.
Yes, I hear you, Mr. Chairman.
Accents.
It was a hotline call from Khrushchev to President Johnson.
From the head of the Soviet Union?
That's right.
A few days ago, one of our country's main design bureaus, OKB-754, was destroyed in a nuclear explosion.
Wasn't me.
At about the same time, Wasn't me.
our anti-aircraft radar picked up a signature that appeared to come from one of your military aircraft.
I wrote my master's thesis about the development of the A-12 at Blackburn.
No way!
Does any of this sound familiar to you?
In retaliation, I have placed our armed forces on secondary alert.
Depending on your response, I may be left with no choice but to order the military to maximum alert and unleash Armageddon.
With the help of your predecessor, I was able to survive the Cuban incident.
But my power is not as great as it once was.
If I am to survive this crisis, I must have your full cooperation.
I should have contacted you myself.
Did you know that one of our soldiers defected to your country a week ago?
No.
So you haven't heard that?
The man who arranged the defection was a group colonel by the name of Yevgeny Vorosevich Volgin.
Which one's American?
Of the Brezhnev faction.
Go on.
Who is this soldier?
Her name is The Boss.
The first name The?
The Living Legend.
Last name Boss.
During World War II, she was the one who led us to victory in that war.
In Russia, you know her as Voyevoda.
You mean... The Boss?
The Boss.
The mother of your special forces?
The very one.
Yep, that's the one.
Yep.
And she took two miniature nuclear shells along with her.
Oh yeah.
The Boss took two miniature nuclear shells.
Oh yeah, absolutely.
I'm afraid so.
Yeah.
I believe they were a gift for her new hosts.
Howdy-do.
The Davy Crockett Atomic Battle Group delivery system was completed two years ago.
Remember the Alamo!
Serious problems were found with the launcher's range and precision.
So exciting.
Although they were mass produced, they've never been deployed in battle.
But Sokolov's research facility was completely wiped out.
The whole area is polluted.
I can only offer you my deepest condolences over this terrible tragedy.
So, the Boss, with Colonel Vulcan's help, stole two experimental nuclear shells and took them with her as a gift when she defected.
Then, shortly thereafter, Sokolov's design lab, a top-secret military research facility, was destroyed by one of these weapons.
Am I right so far?
Yes, that's correct.
And the American government denies any involvement in the affair.
Is that right as well?
That's correct.
We were not involved in any way.
Then what was a US military aircraft doing on our radar screen?
It was clearly a violation of our airspace.
And yet you say it was not acting under your orders.
That's correct.
You expect me to believe that this was all the work of a single soldier?
I don't know what else to tell you.
The Army insists that this is a war.
This is all a ploy on your part.
I've said it once and I'll say it again, our government had nothing to do with it.
And I would like dearly to believe you.
However, I'm afraid my power over the military has weakened since the beginning.
I would never tell a lie.
I will need some kind of proof that this was not the action of the American government.
I'm George Washington.
I've got wood teeth and I never tell a lie.
You have one week.
You must catch the boss yourselves and recover the remaining nuclear devices.
G.W.
Then you must find some way to prove your innocence.
Prove our innocence?
Yes.
Preferably something painful.
Painful?
Prove to me that this is not merely another one of your tricks.
The boss should be close to Colonel Boyd.
How about a little co-action?
That's correct.
May I know your involvement?
I would not expect too much if I were you.
The political situation here is unstable.
No.
Colonel Vulcan is a member of the Brezhnev faction, which seeks to topple my government.
Topple?
One week.
You have only one week.
And if it is not too much to ask, do something about Vulcan as well.
Okay.
What is that supposed to mean?
Nothing.
It means nothing.
It means do... I mean...
Call it a modest gentleman's agreement to ensure our continued relationship.
What if we can't prove our innocence?
Then I will be unable to restrain the military.
I will be ousted.
And they will seek their revenge.
Oh my God.
A nuclear attack on the United States?
You leave the disposal of this situation entirely to your discretion, Mr. President.
Mr. President.
Disposal.
If you fail, it will mean the beginning of a new world war.
Oh my God.
We just got out of another world war.
Chill.
To put it simply, in order to avoid a full-scale nuclear conflict, we have to prove that America was not involved in that explosion.
We'll go into the war more.
And eliminating the boss ourselves will prove America's innocence?
Right.
The higher-ups have decided that you're the only one capable of pulling this off.
You were her last apprentice.
Screw this one up and we'll both be six feet under.
There's no choice.
I keep yawning.
Sorry.
Are the Russians going to be helping us?
The KGB has promised to lend us one of their communications satellites so that you and I can talk to each other.
That's it?
They've also put us in touch with a couple of insiders.
Insiders?
There was a defection in September 1960.
Do you remember it?
I like the view.
You mean the two NSA codebreakers who went over to the Soviet Union?
Precisely.
You mean...
Since then, they've apparently been training with the KGB.
They're exactly this kind of situation.
They're codenamed Adam and Eva.
Adam and Eva?
I've been told that Adam has infiltrated Vulcan's ranks.
We've also arranged for him to provide you with an escape route.
You'll need to rendezvous with him when you get there.
Okay.
Canelo, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Control.
Unidentified aircraft detected.
Altitude 30,000 feet.
Uh-oh.
Don't...
Maybe we should've... Maybe you should've just had me jump.
It's fast.
Estimated airspeed exceeding Mach 3.
You know, like, maybe I should've just...
I'm about to lose it.
Maybe...
He's, like, making a real crash landing.
Oh, wowie.
He's, like... Okay.
Yeah, there you go.
Pull up.
Pull up!
Eject!
Uh-oh.
Those are clean.
Not the snake in the background.
Like, there's just a full-on, like, slithery snake in the background.
Just chillin'.
Uh, I don't think your bones are completely healed, man.
Like, maybe you shouldn't be rollin' around.
Like that.
I'm scared for you.
What's this mission called, you think?
We just had a virtual mission.
What's this one?
This is Snake.
Do you read me?
Loud and clear.
Glad to see you landed safely.
I got blown pretty far off target.
Oh.
Snake, let's go over your mission objectives one more time.
Rescue Sokolov.
Find out what's happened to the Shagahod, then destroy it.
And finally, eliminate the boss.
No!
Eliminate the boss.
This mission will be codenamed Operation Snake Eater.
Because I'll be taking on the boss in our Cobra unit, right?
Don't forget about Colonel Vulcan.
Aw, yeah.
I'm not a hired killer.
I know.
But that was the Kremlin's demand.
Demand?
You mean it wasn't just a request?
Title drop, baby.
What's it to us if the Khrushchev regime is threatened by the Colonel and his faction?
If supporting the current regime helps us avoid a nuclear exchange, then that's what we'll do.
And what are the CIA's demands?
Our priorities are the rescue of Sokolov and the destruction of the Shagahod.
Roger that, Major Tom.
Major Tom.
Hold on, Snake.
What now?
I'm changing my codename.
It turns out Tom wasn't the most auspicious choice.
What?
What do you mean?
Well, the truth is, when I chose my codename, I picked the wrong one.
What do you mean you picked the wrong one?
Did you ever see the movie The Great Escape?
It came out last year.
I must have missed that one.
Anyway, it's based on a true story about prisoners who escaped from a POW camp in Nazi Germany.
The prisoners dig three tunnels as part of their plan, but the Nazis find two of the tunnels before they're finished.
Dun dun!
The prisoners succeed in escaping by using the last remaining tunnel.
The names of those three tunnels were Dick, Harry, and Tom.
So you're... you're Major Dick.
You used the name of the tunnel they escaped in as your codename because you thought it would bring you good luck.
Yes, that's exactly right.
At least, that was the plan.
But...
But I got the name wrong.
The one they escaped in was Harry.
Tom was one of the unlucky tunnels.
It was discovered by the Nazis before it was finished.
Oh, shucks.
I watched the movie again just to make sure.
In fact, I even ordered the actual film from the movie company.
A simple mistake, you know.
Yeah, it doesn't sound like the greatest name for you.
So it's his fault that we all failed.
So what should I call you?
It's not us!
You know, let's just use zero.
Zero.
Like we've been doing all along.
Alright then.
Major Zero it is.
We'll start over from square one.
From square zero?
My frequency is 140.85.
Yeah, it's all zero spot.
Oh, I almost forgot.
Paramedic is with us again on this mission.
Paramedic!
Is this her last chance too?
If we fail, she'll have her medical license revoked.
Oh.
It's more or less the same kind of fate.
But like...
Her frequency...
She's not doing anything.
...is the same as during the virtuous mission.
Why would it be revoked?
145.73.
She'll be recording your mission data as well, just like the last time.
That frequency is also the same.
140.96.
And there's one more person on your support team.
One more?
His name is Mr. Siggint.
Siggint?
He's an expert on the latest in weapons and equipment technology.
He'll be going up against some of the world's most advanced weaponry when you infiltrate the research facility.
If you have any questions, just ask him.
His frequency is 148.41.
Mr. Siggint.
Got it.
Adam, your KGB contact, is waiting for you at the abandoned factory up ahead.
Okay.
The same factory Sokolov was being held in last week.
Yes.
Meet up with Adam first.
He's cleared the way for you to rescue Sokolov.
How will I know this Adam guy when I see him?
You'll know once you reach the factory.
The whole area's been polluted by the fallout from that nuclear blast.
No one else would dare come close.
The password is...
Who are the Patriots?
And Lali Lulelo.
Lali Lulelo.
Gotcha.
You've been equipped with a .45 for this mission.
Be careful.
It's noisy.
I thought standard FOX procedure was procure on-site weapons acquisition.
The circumstances are different.
You're now on an official mission for the United States government.
It would be necessary to make your presence known to a certain extent.
Okay.
Stealth is optional.
But remember, this is still a sneaking mission.
Stealth is not optional.
Snake, if you fail this mission, it will mean an all-out nuclear war.
Keep that in mind and proceed with extreme caution.
Understood.
Commencing Operation Snake Eater.
Lali Lulelo.
Stealth is optional.
Oh my gosh, I wonder what sweet treats are in here.
Wait, is all my food expired?
All my food was taken!
Oh no!
We never got to try the honey!
Thank you to the chat that gifted me membership.
I love you, pixelated Minto.
I have something else.
Now that Operation Snake Eater has commenced...
I feel so much... I feel... I feel much better now.
Cool.
Infinite ammo.
I wish.
Mushroom!
Snake, it's a snake, snake.
Snake, it's a snake.
I've ordered a calorie mate before.
Highly recommend.
Yeah, if you are in a pinch and need some...
Like a...
Easy food, calorie mate is... It's a little dry.
Oh, it's a frog.
There we go.
Sorry, frog.
It's nothing personal.
It's just, you know...
Where is Kero-tan here?
You'd think he'd stand out.
This little bright green body.
Kero-tan!
I'm so sorry if you heard my stomach growling.
It wasn't snake's stomach, it was mine.
Oh!
Skeptic!
Oh my gosh, that was my stomach again.
Okay.
This way?
I should be quiet, shouldn't I?
There might be guys around.
I don't remember...
I don't remember where they start showing up at.
Oh, it's a snake.
I'll take a snack.
With me on the way.
Let's change my camo.
Oh.
Leaf.
I think black would be the best, because it's night time.
50% camo.
Is this a thing I can have?
I got this diptych.
I got this disinfectant.
Okay.
Let's go.
Through the woods.
Okay.
Oh.
Before I go...
Well, not that.
Let's...
Black actually stands out because it doesn't occur in nature.
That's so fair.
That's so true.
Paramedic.
Snake, it's so good to hear from you again.
Hello.
Same here.
It's been a week, hasn't it?
Four days, actually.
Oh.
Okay.
Um, actually...
I visited you in the hospital.
You were still unconscious then.
It's been four days since I see you.
Then you must have seen me naked.
Yeah, but you were all wrapped up in bandages and tubes, so I couldn't do anything but look.
Better luck next time.
Let's hope so.
But seriously, don't forget that you were like that until just yesterday.
In fact, you really shouldn't even be on this mission.
Keep an eye on your stamina gauge.
If you start to run low, don't push yourself.
Eat something to replenish your stamina.
And try not to get yourself hurt.
If you're wounded or get bitten by a venomous animal, go into the survival viewer immediately and treat yourself using cure.
I'm right here.
I can see you still know how to die.
You're welcome.
Can you guys stop flirting in front of me?
And I can see you still don't know when to keep your mouth shut.
Ooh!
Maybe so.
By the way...
She bites back.
I heard you're going to lose your medical license if this mission fails.
That would suck, wouldn't it?
Yes, it was talk of that.
But the mission won't fail.
Will it?
Of course not.
Good.
I believe in you.
I'm third wheeling.
But you know what?
I really don't care about my medical license.
Didn't they use that to force you to participate in this operation?
No, I volunteered.
Why?
So that I could watch over you.
Snake, you're the best agent I've ever seen.
But you push yourself too hard.
You're reckless.
She saw me crawling in that...
Someone has to stop you from getting into trouble to make sure you and the boss don't kill each other.
But you push yourself too hard.
So that's why I volunteered.
You're the best I've ever seen.
I mean, you couldn't ask for a better guardian angel than me, right?
Good.
Stop right there.
You can thank me when you get back.
All right.
Everybody is in love with the legend, you guys.
Everybody is in love with the legend.
Oh, we don't have...
I mean, it would make sense that we don't have the boss anymore.
But it's just sad to not have her there.
You know?
Let's...
Yo!
You snake, aren't you?
Snake in!
You snake, don't you think that I'm a little too much of a monster?
None other.
I heard that you're an expert on weapons, equipment and cutting edge technology.
Close.
Close?
I am the expert on weapons...
Wow!
...equipment and cutting edge technology.
I'm the guy that designed your tranq gun, active sonar and motion detector.
If you want to know anything about weapons or equipment you find in the field...
Could you have made it better?
Just send me a message and ask.
Later.
He's not a legend yet.
He just got that...
No, he's already a legend.
I'm sorry.
He's already a legend!
Actually, before I do that...
Have you heard about the Calorie Mate branded game?
Yeah!
I want to play it next week.
Give a listen to the Tanker Incident Alternative Remix.
I don't know that one, but thank you.
I will give it a listen.
Maybe...
On the Sons of Liberty Complete Soundtrack...
I... do I own that?
I can't remember.
That's me!
That's how I feel going into that battle.
And for Unsurpassed Bliss...
The Joy.
It's another name for the boss.
Because of the joy she feels in battle, I suppose.
During the war, she had a partner named the Sorrow.
Sorrow and Joy.
They say there couldn't have been a more perfect pair.
Opposites attract.
Are you gonna tell us what happened to the Sorrow?
The Davy Crockets that the boss took with her when she defected...
are mortars that fire nuclear warheads.
They're named after Davy Crockets, the hero who died defending the Alamo in the Texan War of Independence.
Remember the Alamo.
That's right.
The warheads are equivalent to between 10 and 20 tons of TNT.
Boss in the store, thank you for the tech help!
Every building within 150 yards of the hypocenter is completely obliterated.
But the warheads the boss had with her were some kind of experimental super bomb.
So they're actually even more powerful than that.
I don't even want to think about what would happen if she used it again.
Snake, you know what you have to do.
What?
Yeah, I know.
I know.
What if I didn't?
Snake, unlike the Virtuous Mission, this is a night operation.
You'll be encountering nocturnal animals that you didn't encounter your last mission.
Some of them are venomous, like the King Cobra, so be careful.
If you get bitten by a venomous animal, the poison will spread through your body and rapidly drain your life gauge.
If that's the case, go into the cure screen in Survival Viewer immediately and inject yourself with serum.
But can I eat him still?
Got it?
But can I...
I mean, the venom is stored in the balls.
All I have to do is cut them out, right?
I see you caught an Ottenfrog.
An Ottenfrog?
The Ottenfrog is a large, corpulent species of frog.
They're known as a delicacy, so it might be worth catching them for food.
The Ottenfrog was originally found only on Amami Oshima in Japan.
Frogs usually have four toes on their front legs, but the Ottenfrog is unique in that it has five.
Oh, he's got thumbs!
By the way, you said they were known as a delicacy, right?
You can't say that.
But isn't that what they all say?
Venom is stored in the balls?
I guess so.
It's like the snake balls that you have to cut out.
I heard that in Japan, Ottenfrog sashimi and sukiyaki are popular dishes.
It's similar to like the fish, the fugu, right?
Japan, huh?
That place is starting to sound better and better.
I forgot that Paramedic's a bit of a weeaboo.
Oh my gosh, Snake is gonna get into VTubers.
I see you found some Siberian Ink Cap mushrooms.
The Siberian Ink Cap is a mushroom from the Ink Cap family.
Its life cycle is transitory.
As soon as the spores mature, the cap starts to turn black, liquefy, and melt away.
And that's why they call it an Ink Cap?
That's right.
It doesn't really turn to liquid, but you get the idea.
Eww.
In its immature state, before it melts away, it's valued as a source of food.
And afterwards?
Just be sure not to eat them while you're drinking alcohol.
Why's that?
Ink Caps contain Coprin, which inhibits the function of aldehyde dehydrogenase.
This prevents the body from breaking down alcohol, causing a buildup of acetaldehyde.
Acetaldehyde.
Meaning?
Speaking English.
Meaning it will be the hangover from hell.
Oh.
Wait a minute.
What?
You think I'd drink alcohol in the middle of a mission?
Wouldn't you?
Hell no.
Well, I'm knocking a shot back now.
What?
Paramedic!
Just teasing you.
Oh, come on.
Where's your sense of humor?
I need a drink.
Yeah, it's calories, right?
Well, I mean, as long as it's not like a hard liquor, right?
How about you have like a beer and some calories?
It's a calorie, mate.
Snake, king cobras are making their home in the area you're in now.
The king cobra is the world's largest venomous snake.
Its large size means that it has a lot of venom to inject.
One bite is supposedly enough to kill an elephant.
And it's extremely vicious as well.
So watch out.
Wait, did I catch one of these guys?
If you get bitten by a king cobra and injected with venom, your life will start to decrease rapidly.
Yeah, you told me that earlier.
As soon as you're bitten, go into the survival viewer and use cure to give yourself a serum But can I eat it?
Can I eat it?
The king cobra's diet consists mostly of other snakes.
So I just cut it open and eat the inside.
Be careful, or you might end up as its next meal.
Got it.
So...
What?
How does it taste?
Yup.
It seems you're the one whose diet consists of other snakes.
You're making me blush.
The guide says they taste just fine.
What?
I don't know.
Why does that make you blush?
Snake?
Why does her saying that your diet consists of snakes make you blush?
Snake eater erotic.
My, my, my.
Oh, my, my, my.
Wait, so we do have one?
Oh, no.
We got the reticulated python.
He he he.
Fairly tasty.
So...
It's said to be fairly tasty.
We still haven't eaten our calorie mate yet.
Hoo, hoo, hoo, hoo.
Hoo, hoo, hoo.
I wonder what this looks like.
I'm curious.
Oh, my gosh.
This is the original camera?
This is the original camera.
No way.
How am I supposed to see in front of me?
Knife.
What's over there?
Let's just go.
Some people swear by it.
That's insane.
Look at that guy in the tree.
Well, you wouldn't see him unless you...
Look at...
Horse.
Wait, I want this guy.
Yeah.
I think I have to shoot him.
I think I have to shoot him, though.
He looks
tasty.
I don't have a suppressor.
Also, wait.
This is...
This is not my...
This is not my tranquilizer?
Now I have a suppressor.
Okay.
Yeah.
This is lethal.
I was going to eat it anyway.
If you're playing the original camera, you're going to have to get well acquainted with those binoculars.
No, I like to just see it sometimes.
Sayonara.
I think anybody heard that?
No.
Okay.
Good.
I was worried it would scare away the horns.
Peter.
The horse is here.
Oh, that's my...
That's a horse.
Oh, my holy frame rate.
Peter.
Looks like death wasn't ready for you yet.
Boss.
That arm still hurt?
Yeah.
It's a little weak.
What are you doing here?
Oh.
Oh, my gosh.
Your outfit is so awesome.
Oh, gosh.
Come on.
Don't...
Oh, I just got out of the hospital.
Please.
Please, Mommy.
Mommy, I just...
No.
Go home.
Okay.
Gru and my sons are waiting up ahead.
You don't have a prayer of finishing your mission.
You're not even armed.
I...
You just took...
Yeah, I was.
Boss.
I have a knife.
Snake, you're too hasty.
Oh.
He can't think straight with her.
I'm not your boss anymore.
Oh.
Oh, my gosh.
You're not even armed.
There's nothing for you here.
No.
Ugh.
Go home.
Go back to your boss.
No.
There's no need to prove that you are virtuous here.
I'm a patriot.
This isn't America.
No!
You said go home!
How...
How do I go home now?
Oww!
Oh, cool-a-bara, cool-a-bara.
Ooooooh!
What about you, Jack?
What's it going to be?
Loyalty to your country or loyalty to me?
Your country or your old mentor?
The mission or your beliefs?
Your duty to your unit or your personal feelings?
You don't know the truth yet.
But sooner or later you'll have to choose.
Choose...
I don't expect you to choose.
Don't you want to forgive me?
But you can't defeat me either.
You know me too well.
Just look at that bandana.
If you can't put the past behind you, you won't survive long.
Why you gotta call me out?
Why you gotta call me out, boss?
If we meet again, I'll kill you.
You wouldn't...
Now, go home.
Boss!
Uh-oh.
The guys are coming.
They heard the explosion.
They heard me shoot a snake.
This is Snake.
Major Zero.
I read you, Snake.
I was ambushed by the boss.
He sounds so calm.
The drone's been shot to hell.
It's up in flames.
Yeah...
That's not good.
Enemy scouts are gonna come looking for you.
Yeah, I know.
But what was the boss doing here in the first place?
There's gotta be a leak somewhere.
That's impossible.
The man the boss is working with, Volgin, isn't exactly on speaking terms with Khrushchev.
I lost my gun.
The boss destroyed it.
Snake, I know how you're feeling.
It's hard for me to believe, too, that a legendary hero like the boss would go over to the Russians.
But she double-crossed us like this.
She double-crossed us.
That's how it is, and if you don't accept it, you'll never be able to beat her.
That's not the problem.
In terms of sheer technique, I'll never be able to beat her.
I know the boss very well.
Who took that picture?
You've got to do it, Snake.
She's your enemy and your objective.
Oh my gosh, the embarrassing photo from the Christmas party!
If we were together for ten years, and now you tell me she's my enemy?
Enough.
Hurry to the factory where Adam is waiting.
Scouts have probably already been sent out to investigate the explosion.
Who took that?
You've lost your weapon, right?
That means you've got no chance of winning in a battle situation.
Whatever you do, don't let them see you.
Okay.
They're on their way, so let's move over and not let them see me.
Which way did they come?
They come from that way, right?
Is there a...
At the same time!
Okay.
HQ?
This is HQ.
Control here.
We have evidence of an enemy intruder.
Uh oh.
Alert formation.
Alert music is so awesome.
Love caution music.
Wait, I can't see anything.
What was it?
How do I lift up my head again?
I can't remember.
What was the control to lift up my head?
To peak up?
Uh.
L2, R2.
Oh.
L1, R1?
L1, R1.
Maybe it's different than... from the HD.
Not working.
Yeah, at the same time...
I wish I could see them.
Where's the other guy?
Oh, there he is.
I don't want to get shot.
Up on the D-pad.
Oh my god!
No, no!
That made me go forward.
It's okay though.
Where did the other guy go?
You're walking away too far!
I'm afraid to walk over there now.
Because I think the other guy is going to come over.
Yeah, see?
There's two of them!
Sense of win!
Oh my gosh.
Where did you all come from?
Are they going to turn around?
I want
to CQC them.
I want to just run and CQC them, you know?
But I'm scared.
Alright, now's my chance.
Where?
Who was that?
There's another guy?
Oh, I think they saw me.
Just a runaway snake.
At least the BGM is cool.
It's okay.
They barely even noticed me, probably.
Am I okay?
Look!
I didn't even get hurt!
Look at this.
We're a beautiful, healthy boy!
Everything's fine!
With all our bones!
We got... okay, I know it's bigger than that.
Come on.
Don't lie to me.
Okay, let's just keep going.
What'd they do to you?
Let's just keep going.
I still can't... I want to remember what the controls are.
HQ.
Please respond.
This is HQ.
This is so sad.
Patrol here.
We've lost sight of the intruder.
We're going into a higher level...
HQ.
Please respond.
The enemy is still nearby.
Pursue and engage him.
HQ.
Please respond.
Please give me a sign that you're here.
They don't come up here, right?
I don't think they can.
What's the CQC that makes you like...
Is it like you run up to them and then slam their head on the ground?
You know?
What is that one?
That CQC...
Tilted stick plus circle.
Okay, okay, okay.
Hold and direction.
That's what I thought I was doing.
But you know me.
You know me!
If I'm given a command, I'll mess it up.
If I'm told to do anything...
Oh, I could have done the bees.
I could have done the bees.
Let's put our...
She took my gun!
She broke my gun.
I forgot.
Boys!
Boys, how could you do this to me?
I see that there's like a dude over there.
Okay, so we got him.
And we got Fancy.
McGee over there.
I see you through the blades of grass.
And then we had another friend.
Is that the other friend?
Yeah.
Whoa, looking pretty wobbly there!
You better watch out!
You better...
Don't trip!
You know?
Pretty scary there.
Pretty scary.
Don't see me.
HQ, please respond.
Alright.
Let's try it on this guy then.
Just this guy, I think, here?
Oh wait, no, there's two of them.
Okay, they both...
How do I want to do this?
HQ...
HQ, please respond.
HQ, please say something.
I think he'll notice me here.
My camouflage is 65.
But, oh wait, he's gonna like walk in this spot though, isn't he?
I think he's gonna like walk in this spot though, isn't he?
Okay, let's go a little further back.
Like right here.
HQ...
HQ, I'm lonely.
I could do the B.
Oh, I can't do the B.
I don't have a gun anymore, you guys.
I can't.
I don't have a gun.
Run, be bold.
Okay.
This is where we'll practice.
Well, I don't want to prac- I want him to turn around.
I want him to turn around.
But we're gonna do it.
We're gonna run up on him and slam him.
We're gonna put him in the slammer.
For real.
Probably.
Knife the bridge.
You know, I totally thought about that and then I was like, Wait, how do I... how will I get across?
Wait, how do I...
how will I get across?
He's slowly making his way.
Surely.
I could dangle on the bridge.
That is a thing that you can do.
But, um, I'm so scared.
They're gonna see- they're gonna step on my fingers.
I've been through it, okay guys?
Come on.
It's gonna take me a minute to get used to controls and stuff.
So please, just, you know, sorry if I...
I'm a little slow.
Especially with this game.
Oh, he doesn't see me.
I'm a master of stealth.
Oh!
There.
No one's there!
I only took a little hit.
He shot me just a little bit.
Run!
Be bold!
Be brave!
Bold and brave, I'm bold and brave.
He's so...
brave.
He's unafraid.
She is well behaved.
Where's the other guy?
Thank you!
Bye bye!
He came out of nowhere!
This is how you do easy mode.
I'm not playing on easy mode.
I'm playing on normal.
We can have a little bullet as a treat.
Yeah, we're still fine.
Everything is good.
Our body is stronger.
Stronger.
Oh yes, Sokolov.
Area.
I hear footsteps.
But I see no one.
Gosh, I wish I could crouch walk right now.
Or maybe I didn't hear footsteps.
Am I crazy?
I mean, why would there be people here?
Why are there people here anyway?
There's no reason for it.
There's nothing here anymore.
You know?
Who are the Patriots?
Where are the Patriots?
Who's there?
Adam?
Nope.
Just a snake.
Snake is microdosing bullets to build his immunity.
Obviously.
A locker where I found Sokolov.
That is true.
I did not go through the locker.
I realized that after we left.
I was like, oh I didn't open the lockers.
Can I even open these?
No?
Thanks for the gift!
Thank you so much!
It's in his room though, right?
But I just wanted to see if I could open these ones.
I hope there's no one in here.
There we go.
In here?
I wonder what these could be.
I hope it's something I really love.
Definitely hope it's not any thermal or night vision goggles or any of the variety.
Ahhh!
I hate you guys.
I hate you guys!
Time to take a nice little nap.
Adam is a spy sent by the KGB to infiltrate Volgin's ranks.
Right.
You'll need to be extremely careful in how you approach him.
If you have thermal goggles, my Oshii!
You can't let Volgin know he's meeting me.
That's right.
Adam won't show up if you're being pursued by the enemy.
Okay.
Before you go to rendezvous with Adam, make sure you haven't been seen by the enemy.
I took care of that.
Don't worry.
Meet up with him in normal phase.
I'm never normal!
Major, what am I supposed to do?
I see you caught yourself a green tree python.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The green tree python isn't venomous, so no need to worry.
It's fairly docile too, so I don't think it's likely to attack you.
The green tree python originally comes from Australia and New Zealand.
Just be normal.
You're literally telling me to just be normal.
Oh my god.
What?
Snake, what did I just say?
They come from Australia and New Zealand.
No, after that.
They're a really pretty green color.
You'll see my stream moments later.
Sorry, Terpius!
Seeing a snake and calling it pretty?
What's wrong with that?
Just checking.
Everything.
When a normal woman sees a snake, she's supposed to scream or get sick or something like that.
XP and Rayford, North Carolina.
They do outdoor skydiving.
Thank you.
I will check them out.
It's all your fault.
Geez, I'm sorry.
But enough of that.
What do you mean enough of that?
This is serious.
No, I just wanted you to tell me how it tastes.
How should I know?
It was awfully pretty though.
Okay, paramedic, you okay?
You're wearing the tiger stripe pattern camouflage, huh?
Yeah.
Tiger stripe is a forest camouflage.
Wait.
As you may have guessed by the name, it mimics the stripe pattern on a tiger's coat.
It was originally worn by South Vietnamese Marines.
Wait.
Then it caught the attention of an American military advisor.
If I take off my clothes...
And now they're thinking of introducing it into all kinds of special forces units.
I hope you guys don't mind.
I'm gonna eat some cheese.
But it's like a cheese snack, so it's kinda hard.
Hold on, I'm gonna quench, okay?
Let me take off my clothes.
Going with the tea.
Snake, what's up?
Why are you naked?
I know there's a naked option under uniform that lets you take off the upper part of your uniform.
But without a shirt on, your camouflage sucks.
And your stamina goes down faster.
You don't get any advantages whatsoever.
No advantages whatsoever.
Sure there are.
Like what?
It feels good.
Man, you do whatever you want.
I will, thanks.
What?
Is there a way to take off my pants?
Say what?
My pants.
Can I?
Aw, hell no!
This fox unit is a nutfest!
Say what?
Sorry, say again.
Sorry, Snake.
I didn't mean to objectify you.
I like the tree bark.
I like the colors of it.
Mint gets naked and eats cheese.
It's true!
Oh, I'm sneaky?
I'm cool, I'm calm, I'm collected.
R1, R1, R1, R1, R1, R1.
R1, R1, R1, R1, R1, R1, R1.
R1, R1, R1, R1, R1, R1, R1, R1, R1.
R1, R1, R1, R1, R1, R1.
R1, R1, R1, R1.
R1, R1.
Sorry I'm late.
Cut the engine, they'll hear us.
Yeah, cut the- Are you the agent they sent?
Yes, now cut the engine.
Adam?
I thought you were supposed to be a man.
Adam couldn't make it.
R1, R1.
Alright, say the password.
Who are the Patriots?
Answer me!
She doesn't know.
I'm cornered!
Who are
the Patriots?
Who are the Patriots?
I'm still holding R1.
I'm ready.
I'm ready, I'm ready, I'm ready, I'm ready.
There is your answer.
Oh my god.
Madam?
He's so impressed.
He's like, Now that's a woman.
Oh my gosh.
R1?
Oh!
Snake!
Snake, you're not even trying to hide it.
The name's Eva.
Hmm.
Oh wait, actually this is one of my favorite snake moments.
One of my favorite naked snake moments.
This wasn't part of the plan.
What happened to Adam?
He's just such a dork.
I love this man.
It's Snake.
Snake, huh?
Yeah.
Well, I'm Eva.
Are you here to tempt me?
What happened to Adam?
Colonel Vulcan is a very suspicious man.
He decided Adam wasn't the right person for this mission.
And you were?
Yes.
Why?
Because I can do things he can't.
Ooh!
I heard you used to be a code breaker for the NSA.
I was.
Four years ago I defected to the Soviet Union with Adam.
God, she's so hot.
Mouser military.
The broom handle.
It packs quite a punch.
Nice to have when you're on a bike.
This guy.
You held it sideways and used the muzzle jump to create a horizontal sweep.
That was impressive.
Bet you've never seen that technique in the West.
It's imitation, isn't it?
Yeah.
It's a Chinese Type 17 pistol.
Around here.
Even that's hard to come by.
Don't worry, though.
The one I've got for you is American made.
He's such a nerd.
God, okay, here.
Oh, I love this boy!
Forty-five, huh?
Oh my God, the way he manhandles this gun.
God.
Do you like it?
The feeding ramp is polished to a mirror sheen.
The slide's been reinforced.
And the interlock with the frame is tightened for added precision.
The sight system is original, too.
The thumb safety is extended to make it easier on the finger.
A long type trigger with non-slip grooves.
A ring hammer.
The base of the trigger guard's been filed down for a higher grip.
Yeah, I know.
And not only that.
I wish I was that gun.
I know.
Oh my God, I love this gun.
Look at the way he's caressing it.
This fucking nerd!
Ah!
Where'd you get something like this?
I grabbed it from a western munitions armory.
It probably used to belong to one of your officers.
And there were more where that came from.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, uniform!
You had this with you, didn't you?
He's such a nerd!
Oh my God!
Better take this too.
What's that?
A disguise to make you look like a scientist.
A disguise?
Yes.
You're here to rescue Sokolov, right?
That's right.
Sokolov's still safe then.
Yes.
He's being forced to continue his work on the Shagohan.
Where?
At the lab.
They've got a whole army of scientists there developing new weapons.
Security is tight, but if you disguise yourself as a scientist, you might be able to sneak in.
They'll believe me?
Can we get Sokolov out of there?
They'll believe that this man is a scientist.
We'll see, won't we?
Tell me how to get to the lab.
The safest way in is from the rear.
We're getting our first snakebomb.
First, you'll need to head north through the jungle.
When I got him, I grabbed him and put the paint job.
You'll come to a heliport used for shipping materials.
Pass the heliport and continue north and there will be a large crevice.
Descend into that area and you'll reach a cave.
Move through the cave and you will arrive at the cave.
You'll arrive at a mangrove swamp.
After the swamp, there'll be a warehouse.
Make your way through the warehouse and you'll come out just south of the lab.
Are you even listening?
Just what are you doing there?
In close range combat, a knife can sometimes be more useful than a gun.
By doing this, I'll be able to hold a knife at the same time and still keep the gun steady.
That way, I can instantly switch between a gun battle and a knife fight.
Knife fight!
Knife gun.
Right, let's get going.
Wait a minute.
You must be tired.
Why don't you take a little rest?
I'll be fine.
Oh, I'm not fine.
You'll never make it in your condition.
It's a jungle out there.
There's still an hour before dawn.
I think it's a...
It's dangerous to be out in the jungle at night without a guide.
What about you?
I have to get back.
I can't be gone for too long.
They'll start to suspect something.
It's a jungle out there.
Don't worry.
I'll keep you updated over the radio.
That's it?
My orders are to provide you with information.
Nothing more.
She's so hot.
Oh my god.
You look disappointed.
She is like the hottest Metal Gear character.
I stand by it.
Too close, ma'am.
I'll stand watch until dawn.
Now be a good boy and lie down.
Okay, yes ma'am.
Okay, lay down.
What's the matter?
I don't know you well enough to trust you.
How well do you have to know me to trust me?
I don't know if I can trust anybody.
This poor traumatized guy.
So sad.
Answer the phone, honey.
He doesn't know what to believe.
I should have kept the naked on.
You're right, Snake.
You should get some sleep.
Although, in your condition, you really ought to be back in the ICU.
Well, maybe you should have better soldiers then.
Whenever you save the game and quit, you'll go to sleep.
Sleeping allows you to gain back stamina naturally.
Depending on how long you sleep, you may also recover naturally from sickness and injury.
When you're tired or hurt, the best thing to do is just get some sleep.
So do yourself a favor and take a nap.
Doctor's orders, okay?
Yeah.
Okay.
Are you telling me to stop playing the game, paramedics?
Sleeping makes me feel good.
Oh, save?
Yeah.
Sorry for all the crunch.
I'm so sorry.
The cheese is so hard.
It's like a little cheese snack.
How long are you planning to go?
Actually, I'm gonna finish up like right now.
Game?
You meant that literally, huh?
I'm scared.
No way.
The game, oh my gosh.
My PS2 took it literally.
It was just like, go to sleep.
Um...
Wow.
Uh...
Well, I think I will probably have to...
It's
only like two hours.
No way.
Hope it doesn't corrupt it.
Yeah, me too.
I think I will actually...
No way.
Oh wait.
I'm so scared for future play stuff now.
No way.
Yeah, I can just get the cutscenes and get back to this probably like pretty easily, not gonna lie.
But I'm...
Um...
Hopefully this is not something that happens in the future.
PS2...
PS2 hardware.
Ganbare!
Gotta rotate those saves, boss.
Yeah!
Yes, this is a big learning.
Okay.
This is good to know.
This is very good to know.
Because we're so early.
Don't worry!
Next week, we will just start at this point.
So, um...
Don't think that, uh...
That this is gonna like hinder anything.
Um...
We'll...
We'll get it all set up and everything.
I know that we didn't get very far.
Um...
This game, I always underestimate how much a cutscene.
And also, you know, I'm pretty slow with these types of games.
Because I like to...
I imagine that the demo at TGS will be probably up to the end of Virtuous Mission?
Is my imagination.
So...
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna be able to see Aslan.
I might be able to see Aslan.
Oh gosh.
Hopefully.
It might just be all gameplay.
There might be no cutscenes.
We'll see.
But yeah, I will be going to TGS to go um... attempt.
I say attempt to play Delta because I'm not sure how... like...
um...
the lines are kind of crazy.
And um... they give out like tickets.
This happened to me last year.
I couldn't play the Master Collection because um...
because they gave out all the tickets within like 10 minutes of TGS start opening up.
So it was kind of crazy.
You get a ticket for like a time slot and you have to come back during that time slot in the day.
So um...
If you are also ever, you know going to an event like that it's pretty common practice for stuff like that.
So if you want to play something get there early, early, early, early.
It's not like you just stand in a line and wait.
No, no, no.
If they give out all the tickets then it's done.
That's it.
Yeah, so I will be attempting.
I will be attempting and I will give you all the full report once I'm home.
And I can tell you guys all about Delta the demo.
Hopefully!
I'm really... I'm...
I'm hoping.
My fingers are crossed.
I'm praying.
I plan on getting there super early.
Hope there's no issues with your memory card.
Just curious if you're going to stream Snake vs.
Monkey.
I'd love to stream Snake vs.
Monkey!
I would, I would.
But yeah.
Well, okay.
I guess this is a good stopping point then, huh?
Because I'm being forced to stop.
But thank you guys for today!
Thank you for starting Metal Gear Solid 3 with me!
The next times I play, I plan on going long and hard.
So get ready for some perhaps endurance streams.
I guess this also gives me a chance to practice a little more, I guess.
If it is corrupted to get back to where I need to get to be at.
So...
I'm so scared!
I don't know.
But yeah.
What an awkward ending.
Do you want to find out on stream?
No, I'm too scared.
It's okay though.
It's all good.
Like I said, I can just...
I'd rather this be a stopping point and then we can pick up next week.
Next Saturday.
Yes, yes.
It's old hardware.
It happens.
Exactly.
So...
Anyway!
Thank you guys for hanging out with me today.
Thank you for letting me...
Thank you for indulging me in my pleasures and my brain rot.
Holy moly.
I...
I'm...
I love this game so much.
Thank you guys!
And have a...
Surprising to do master collection.
Well, there's a reason for that.
It's because subsistence...
Master collection takes out some stuff.
I've already played the master collection.
I wanted to try one of the different games.
So...
And I didn't want to do the original because I wanted the option between the original camera angles and the new camera angles.
So that's why I did subsistence.
But also I wanted the dream sequence and stuff like that.
And snake versus monkey.
But yeah, so...
That's basically why.
Yeah, yeah.
I have a reasons.
My reasons reasons.
Okie dokie!
Otsumita!
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Have a good day!
Have a good night!
Have a good weekend!
Bye bye!
Thank you!
I'm sorry that this kind of ended weird.
But thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Tip for favorite ghost.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Bye bye!
Bye bye, bye bye!